le président Lafont et moi-même
utilisant une autorité toute relative
pour vous dire qu'il faut prendre place
et que
nous allons débuter notre réunion de
commission dont je rappelle
elle concerne l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 à Paris également
peut-être un point sur la Coupe du monde
de rugby en tous les cas les conditions
de sécurité et que l'audition du
ministre c'est Darmanin est retransmise
sur le site internet du Sénat en direct
je crois et je voulais le redire merci
monsieur le ministre au nom du Président
Lafont et de moi-même de votre présence
cet après-midi au Sénat ou une nouvelle
fois ne réunissons nos deux commissions
afin d'évoquer les sujets que je viens
de rappeler
le rapport que nous avons commis au
moment des événements du Stade de France
avait permis sur
d'identifier un certain nombre de
difficultés dans les grandes
manifestations sportives et avait été
aussi l'occasion de nous interroger sur
l'organisation future à la fois de la
Coupe du monde de rugby à la fois de des
Jeux Olympiques 2024 à cela avait été
dit qu'un texte viendrait prochainement
sur l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
notamment avec des propositions de votre
part qui a eu un travail de préparatoire
qui a été fait bien sûr et le président
de la foi et moi-même avions souhaité
que vous puissiez venir devant nos deux
commissions
pour regarder étudier et discuter avec
vous de cette présentation et de travail
qui était actuellement fait voilà je ne
veux pas en dire plus vous avez annoncé
qui aurait peut-être 18 nouvelles
brigades mobiles et vous aviez annoncé
qu'il y aurait probablement un recours à
la vidéoprotection je parle là plus pour
la commission des lois dont c'est le
suggère des sujets importants et
notamment parce que deux collègues trois
collègues de la commission des lois en
commis un rapport sur la reconnaissance
faciale et donc quelque part sur ce qui
pourrait être utilisé dans le cadre de
ces deux grandes compétitions savoir si
vous aurez recours ou pas dans quelles
conditions juridique et naturellement
contribuer à ce que cela se passe dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
voilà moi j'en ai terminé je vais
laisser le président à fond la
naturellement la parole et je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le président de la
commission des bois moi je ne serai pas
tellement plus long dans ce propos
introductif parce que nous allons vous
céder la parole dans quelques instants
monsieur le ministre d'abord pour vous
remercier comme l'après fait le
président de buffet d'être devant nous
de nouveau devant nos deux commissions
pour poursuivre cet échange vous l'aviez
proposé vous-même du reste de revenir
après l'été
suite au premier échanges que nous
avions eu au rapport que nous avions
adopté à l'unanimité qui
établissait 15 recommandations pour
améliorer la sécurité lors des grands
événements sportifs nous avons en commun
ce souhait que les grands événements
sportifs à venir à savoir la Coupe du
monde de rugby et bien sûr des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques se passent
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et on sait que de ce point de vue là la
question de la sécurité est un enjeu
essentiel à la bonne tenue de ces
événements sportifs c'est non seulement
un enjeu ça devient une préoccupation
des Français si on fait référence à des
sondages parus
récemment alors on sait bien que toutes
les décisions n'ont pas encore été
prises qui a un certain nombre de
réflexions en cours néanmoins il nous
paraît important de vous entendre de
nouveau et de pouvoir vous interroger
sur notamment les recommandations que
nous avions
formulés et les réflexions qui sont les
vôtres à ce jour en tant que président
de la commission culture je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de faire un aussi une petite
parenthèse sur les grands événements
culturels puisqu'on a vu début septembre
qui avait eu des incidents lors d'un
concert de Booba au Stade de France je
ferai pas le parallèle avec la finale
Champions League mais là aussi il y
avait il y a eu un problème de de
billetterie avec des des
faux billets qui ont été
mis en circulation c'est dire que la
problématique demeure et donc évidemment
nous avons à cœur de vous entendre cet
après-midi pour faire un point à date
sur les décisions que d'ores et déjà été
prise et celle qui reste à prendre ce
ministre nous donnons la parole
merci Messieurs les Présidents mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je me suis
permis de proposer un petit présentation
vous avez bien voulu accepter pour que
l'ensemble de la Commission puisse
suivre peut-être le cheminement qui
m'amène à présenter les moyens que le
ministère de l'Intérieur va mettre en
place pour organiser la Coupe du monde
de rugby mais surtout les Jeux
olympiques de Paris donc j'ai pas besoin
de rappeler ici je le rappellerai quand
même l'importance pour notre pays mais
aussi le côté exorbitant de l'action que
va mener ministère de l'Intérieur
puisque le Premier ministre Valls avait
désigné mes prédécesseurs et donc
moi-même comme étant l'unique
responsable de l'organisation en termes
de sécurité des événements sportifs et
c'est également des Jeux olympiques de
Paris d'abord c'est l'objet de ce
premier ce premier slide comment dirait
en patois Tourcoing c'est-à-dire le fait
que nous nous inscrivons dans la loi que
vous venez de voter à une très large
majorité je vous en remercie une
nouvelle fois encore
sur la loopmie puisque on avait besoin
de moyens très important pour finalement
répondre à quatre types de menaces qui
pèsent sur les grands événements
sportifs et segments sur les Jeux
Olympiques
à Paris d'abord un monastère sans aucune
espèce de doute le menace tordre public
ce que vous faites référence aussi
monsieur le Président une menace cyber
je rappelle que aux Jeux Olympiques de
Tokyo c'est 4 milliards d'attaques cyber
qui ont concernés des Jeux Olympiques de
Tokyo et il n'y avait pas de public du
fait du covid et une menace qu'on
pourrait appeler délinquante qu'on a
rajouté si j'ose dire aspirer notamment
des faits du Stade de France
je j'expliquerai comment on arrive à
avoir des moyens vraiment très
importants pour la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques des 15 milliards d'euros vous
les avez accordé dans la loopy donc
merci au Sénat le texte arrive à
l'Assemblée la semaine prochaine en
commission de grandes priorités c'est
évidemment l'augmentation très très
forte de la présence de la de la voie
publique alors là on l'a vu avec la
création de de gendarmes de ce cadran de
gendarmerie et de CRS on en reparlera
mais ça c'est dans la locmi le numérique
et la technologie j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire à quel point c'était une loi de
cyber et de technologie sur les 15
milliards la moitié concernent la
technologie à transformation numérique
et cyber du ministère de l'Intérieur et
puis il y avait une poche si j'ose dire
de 200 millions d'euros qui sont
d'ailleurs dans la première année de
l'année 2023 puisque le PLF va arriver
devant vous Mesdames et Messieurs les
dessinateurs pour refaire la quasi
intégralité des salles de commandement
dans les dans les préfectures concernées
notamment à la préfecture de police mais
surtout au ministère de l'intérieur où
nous aurons une nouvelle salle de
commandement de gestion de crise qui
servira demain à d'autres choses comme
la gestion des attentats ou les
détournements d'avion vous savez que
c'est ministère de l'Intérieur qui est
le lieu où on se retrouve les autorités
de l'État a commencé par président de la
République en cas de crise qu'on appelle
la CIC le sujet de la vidéoprotection on
parlera des moyens légaux
supplémentaires dont on va demander la
la la l'augmentation au parlementaire
mais aussi en moyenne budgétaire on en
reparlera et le nombre de caméras qu'on
va rajouter sur voie publique ainsi que
la lutte anti-drone que je partage avec
le ministre des Armées puisque
aujourd'hui la police de l'air
présidentielle notamment à Paris et
celle du gouverneur militaire de Paris
donc c'est une menace très importante
que nous découvrons toutes tous pour
éviter que nous ayons pas des attentats
comme sur des des scènes de guerre que
nous connaissons malheureusement autour
de théâtre d'opérations extérieures de
drone chargé d'explosif qui arrive sur
sur une foule par exemple là nous co
partageons cette responsabilité avec
donc je veux dire que d'abord la
communion de rugby qui arrive désormais
dans quelques mois dans dix mois et pour
moi pour nous pour le ministère
intérieur de répétition générale et que
nous allons mobiliser 7000 forces de
l'ordre par jour pour cette événement
c'est-à-dire
beaucoup de force de l'ordre même si on
verra que c'est beaucoup plus évident
pour les Jeux Olympiques 7000 par jour
c'est évidemment une moyenne puisque
c'est pas la même chose en finale que
dans les matchs de moindre importance
mais c'est beaucoup de monde on aura
l'occasion de revenir si vous le
souhaitez je voudrais aussi souligner
que sur les Jeux Olympiques nous allons
gérer 10500 athlètes de deux sensations
représentées c'est-à-dire y compris des
nations qui peuvent avoir des menaces
extrêmement importantes sur leurs
équipes pour penser évidemment l'équipe
israélienne à l'équipe américaine à les
représentants évidemment de d'autres
pays que je n'aurais pas
souligner ici mais qui mérite
effectivement une protection toute
particulière 46 de compétition je
rappelle que la moitié de ces sites au
moins sont en Île-de-France et singul à
Paris et en Seine-Saint-Denis et 7 au
même en hyper centre de Paris ce qui met
des défis logistiques de sécurité très
important 6000 journalistes qu'il faut
aussi évidemment accompagner protéger
quasiment 10 millions de spectateurs il
n'y a pas d'équivalent aux Jeux
olympiques d'été 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs quand il se passera mal
quelque chose à Paris ou reste dans le
reste du pays où tout le monde le verra
et ce sera vu immédiatement 22 villes
qui vont accueillir des épreuves jusque
on Polynésie française ce qui demande
évidemment des projections de force bien
évidemment qui pose d'autres menaces sur
maire notamment on pense aussi aux
épreuves qui seront à Marseille 13
millions de billets vendus à compter de
février 2023 je voudrais ici dire j'ai
entendu la question sur la biéthique que
si le miso intérieur et le gouvernement
est responsable de la sécurité
d'organisation et des pas responsable de
la vie éthique et du fonctionnement de
chacun des événements en tant que tel
puisque là il y a un comité
d'organisation comité d'organisation que
vous connaissez bien notamment que
Monsieur Estang
président sans doute de reparler de nos
liens avec ce comité d'organisation
évidemment mais chacun évidemment
s'occupe de sa chacune lumière si j'ose
dire les Jeux olympiques sont complétés
par des Jeux paralympiques qui vont donc
amener la France à avoir de nouveau
énormément d'athlètes 4400 athlètes pour
549 matchs ou sessions et notamment vous
l'avez vu c'est une ouverture série
d'ouverture également on parlera celle
de la de la des Jeux olympiques du mois
de juillet mais la cérémonie d'ouverture
de des Jeux paralympiques se tiendra
manifestement place de la Concorde
c'est-à-dire en plein centre de Paris au
moment où Paris va reprendre son
activité économique scolaire naturel
évidemment il est bien difficile de
sécuriser la place de la Concorde on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler donc j'ai
évoqué les risques je n'y reviendrai pas
mais on peut aussi les compléter par des
menaces qui auraient pu faire hier
sourire mais qui ne font moins sourire
depuis la guerre en Ukraine une menace
nucléaire menace radiologique des
menaces biologiques ou chimiques tout ce
qui pourrait être ressembler à des
bombes aux attentats qu'on pourra
appeler de salles il y a pas de ta
propre mais vous voyez ce que nous
pouvons vivre évidemment c'est menaces
sont extrêmement nombreuses ne sont pas
que des menaces dans le public
alors nous allons et c'est la première
fois que je divise que Monsieur les
présidents ces chiffres nous allons
mobiliser plus de 30 000 policiers
gendarmes par jour pour tous les moments
de des Jeux Olympiques c'est-à-dire sur
un gros mois
ça va donc
demander
énormément de travail de préparation et
d'exécution pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur je vais aussi dire que je
fais deux fois par semaine une réunion
sur la préparation de la Coupe du monde
de rugby et des Jeux Olympiques je
précise moi-même le comité tous les mois
d'ensemble de mes directeurs je réunis
sans cesse préfet demain les élus locaux
qui seront concernés on peut dire que
les Jeux Olympiques les couillons de
rugby prend un bon tiers de montant de
ministre de l'Intérieur et organiser les
Jeux Olympiques et mobiliser 30 000
policiers gendarmes par jour évidemment
c'est un défi que la France n'a jamais
mis en place pour la seule Île-de-France
la préfecture de police va définir
manifestement selon les jours bien
évidemment entre 12000 et 45 000 forces
de l'ordre avec un point d'orgue qui est
la série limite d'ouverture on y
reviendra qui se tiendra comme vous le
savez pour la première fois en dehors
d'un stade dans l'histoire des Jeux
Olympiques et comme on aime bien les
difficultés sur la scène
avec 600 000 spectateurs
nous y reviendrons
on va donc imaginer un certain nombre de
scénarios de sécurité a commencé par
celui des transports en commun il y aura
en Île-de-France et notamment dans la
première couronne et la ville de Paris
700 patrouille au moment où nous
parlerons à chaque fois que nous
parlerons il y aura au moins 700
patrouilles de policiers de gendarmes
c'est-à-dire que
la saturation l'espace public par les
forces de l'ordre sera je crois visible
à l'oeil à l'oeil nu
la réussite de la sécurité au transport
en commun et évidemment un exemple mais
c'est un exemple marquant pour vous dire
qu'évidemment on s'intéresse pas à ce
qui se passe dans le stade ou aux arbres
du stade mais de l'Inter monde de la
sécurité on pourrait l'appeler comme ça
des choses olympiques donc comment le
ministre de l'Intérieur arrive à
mobiliser 30 000 policiers gendarmes par
jour je rappelle qu'il y a 250 000
policiers et gendarmes tout confondus au
moment où nous parlons avec évidemment
des gens qui sont en congé des gens qui
sont absents des gens qui sont en
formation des gens qui ne peuvent pas
être sur le terrain des gens qui sont
donc on va dire que la
la basse des policiers des gendarmes
mobilisables c'est en fait
140 150 000 personnes sur les 250 000
avant la lotmi et donc pour avoir trop
envie policiers gendarmes par jour
mobilisés sans compter qu'évidemment la
France va continuer à vivre il y aura
toujours des appels 17 des feux des
actes de délinquance malheureusement des
manifestations parfois même des
manifestations culturelles sportives
ailleurs on entend qu'il y aurait plus
de 3000 clubs par exemple Jeux
Olympiques dans chacune des communes de
France pour que chacun puisse regarder
sur un écran gérant de la place du
village des Jeux Olympiques bon bref la
France va continuer à vivre
indépendamment de ces Jeux Olympiques il
faut donc qu'on garde une grande
politique de sécurité par tout ailleurs
et qu'on la concentre sur les vins sites
les 20 à 20 départements qui connaissent
l'arrivée de des Jeux Olympiques et je
vous fais grâce de la flamme qui va
traverser évidemment toute notre pays
qui connaît évidemment la même la même
sécurité
d'abord j'ai pris une décision qui n'est
pas législative donc je ne vous embête
pas avec ça c'est pour ça je n'étais pas
dans l'autre mi je mets fin le temps des
Jeux Olympiques et le temps de la Coupe
du monde de rugby à la zone entre police
et gendarmerie rien n'empêche un
policier et agenda d'aller dans la zone
de compétences naturelles de l'autre il
n'y a pas de frontière comme une police
municipale pourrait pas aller dans une
autre commune c'est tellement vrai que
vous voyez des gendarmes mobiles venir
dans la zone police lorsqu'on a besoin
d'eux ou que de temps en temps des psigs
vont c'était le cas d'un événement
au stade de Nice et de Marseille se
tenir leurs collègues policiers mais
j'ai dit aux deux directeurs généraux de
la police de gendarmerie que je voulais
pas entendre parler de zone de
compétences donc nous puissions utiliser
mentalement et physiquement
l'intégralité des ressources policières
et gendarmesques pour les concentrer là
où on a besoin d'eux c'est à dire où il
y a les événements et singulièrement
Île-de-France mais pas que en
Île-de-France donc il n'y aura plus de
zone de compétences plus gendarmerie ça
peut s'exprimer de deux manières
soit parce que nous enverrons des
gendarmes dans une police on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer c'est ce que le
scénario sur lequel nous travaillons
qu'on donne par exemple des missions au
gendarmes en zone police tenir une gare
par exemple tenir un réseau de transport
donc l'idée ça une unité de commandement
de dire je prends l'exemple de la gare
de Saint-Denis évidemment les arbitrages
ne sont pas faits que le maire de
Saint-Denis ne soit pas étonné que je
parle de sa commune mais chacun comprend
pourquoi j'en parle devant la difficulté
parfois de tenir les événements
plusieurs événements sportifs en même
temps en à Saint-Denis par exemple pour
imaginer que les gendarmes soient
responsables de la gare de Saint-Denis
intégralement et de son réseau de
transport qui l'amène et que les
policiers soient responsables de des
rues du centre-ville et de l'accès
direct au stade donc on pourrait
imaginer des zones dans la zone afin que
une mission égale un chef égale un
résultat et je reparlerai tout à l'heure
de la l'objectif de 0 délinquance que
j'ai donné aux forces de l'ordre et
notamment comment on peut y arriver
deuxièmement on peut aussi imaginer
qu'on utilise des policiers qui sont
dans des territoires de province qui
pourrait être envoyé dans des zones
police pour être renforcées que les
gendarmes les remplacent le temps de la
compétition si nous sommes dans le
Calvados j'ai pris cet exemple plusieurs
fois il y a pas d'annonce particuliers
pour les policiers les gendarmes du
Calvados mais pour imaginer qu'une
grande partie du commissariat de quand
est et de Lisieux puissent être affectés
en Île-de-France pendant ce mois de
compétition et qu'on demande aux
gendarmes de prendre la zone des
communes non directement concernées par
la vie de capital préfectoral par
exemple quand et que les communes autour
de Caen soient le temps de la
compétition elle gérée par la
gendarmerie en tout cas l'idée
principale de cette manœuvre c'est
d'oublier des compétences police et
gendarmerie encore une fois aucune
disposition législative n'est nécessaire
il s'agit simplement de soulever des
barrières mentales dont vous savez
qu'elles sont parfois très très
importantes j'ai demandé à tous les
préfets de me rendre pour la fin de ce
mois
une première et quelques-uns me les ont
déjà entendu première proposition de
sécurisation des lieux d'entraînement
parce que ces athlètes vont s'entraîner
des spectateurs vont aller les voir
quand il s'agit de compétitions de
d'équipe qui sont très sensibles je
parlais de l'État d'Israël par exemple
une protection évidemment donc les lieux
d'entraînement les fans que vont créer
au fur et à mesure les communes il y a
bien sûr les diverses
occupations autour de chacune et de
chacun des des équipes des compétiteurs
face à un être de l'engouement j'ai donc
demandé au préfet de mon premier
définition plus important étant bien sûr
le préfet de police des zones sensibles
et des lieux qui valaient concerner avec
les moyens qu'ils demandent et je leur
demanderai une carte à chacune à chacun
d'entre eux que je challengerai
personnellement pour savoir justement
quel est leur proposition de répartition
de un chef émission un endroit qui garde
la gare de Châteauroux puisqu'il y a des
épreuves à Châteauroux qui s'occupent de
la la sécurité publique en général dans
la ville de Châteauroux et qui s'occupe
en particulier des événements autour de
jeux olympiques à Châteauroux c'est
voilà un département qui peut permettre
par exemple donner aux gendarmes qui
sont assez puissants si j'ose dire en
nombre d'effectifs dans la région
puisqu'il faut aussi loger ces personnes
il faut évidemment qu'ils puissent
rencontrer leurs familles qui puisse
déjeuner enfin tout un tas de problèmes
évidemment c'est extrêmement pratique il
est avec leur matériel on peut imaginer
un certain nombre de liberté avec ces
zones pour correspondre à ce moment qui
va nous permettre de maximiser la
présence sur la voie publique le
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment de
d'utiliser les élèves des écoles de
police et gendarmerie ils seront 7000 au
moment des Jeux Olympiques cette ville
parce que vous avez accordé dans la
loterie le fait que j'en crée 3000 dans
la police et 3000 dans la gendarmerie
les deux premières années budgétaires
donc en fait on a deux fois plus
d'élèves l'année prochaine et l'année
d'après dans les zones dans les écoles
de police et de gendarmerie et après les
8 mois de formation puisque je rappelle
que lorsque je suis arrivé les policiers
gendarmes faisaient nouvelle formation
désormais ils en font 12 donc les 7000
ce que j'anticipe une question
seront-ils assez formés seront formés
comme les anciens si j'ose dire non pas
passer le bloc OPJ mais c'est pas
extrêmement grave à ce moment-là et
seront utilisés pour des
de la présence qui n'est pas la même que
celle d'une police d'intervention mais
pourra aider les agents de sécurité
privée là où ils seront défaillants
pourra accompagner les personnes autour
des stades pour aider évidemment à
renseigner notamment dans les appels 17
où en lien avec les pompiers donc il y a
7000 élèves de police de gendarmerie que
je peux mobiliser en plus qu'on ne fait
pas d'habitude et nous porterons à 8500
le nombre de réservistes par par
mobilisation c'est juste dire que nous
pourrons faire avec des crédits qui ont
forte augmentation de la gendarmerie
nationale qui sait faire ce genre de
mobilisation c'est à peu près 7000 pour
les pour les gendarmes et la police
nationale vous avez accepté la création
de sa réserve dans la loi sécurité
globale on sera autour de 1500 policiers
citoyens on les appelait comme ça qui
stabiliser pour les Jeux Olympiques
évidemment pour nous l'important est la
manœuvre c'est aussi l'annulation ou le
rapport de tous les événements en France
qui demandent des unités de force mobile
en qui demandent voilà la présence très
forte de nombre de policiers on pense à
des grands festivals culturels qui ont
lieu pendant l'été on pense à de grands
événements sportifs qui méritent d'être
sans doute un peu décalé et qui parfois
parcourt la France à vélo par exemple
des grands concerts à certains nombre de
grands événements pense à la braderie de
Lille si je parle de ma région où il
s'agit pas de les interdire mais de
pouvoir les reporter dans le temps en
lien évidemment avec les élus bien sûr
nous avons ce travail en ce moment même
ne serait-ce que pour que les
programmations culturelles puissent être
en cohérence avec l'argent dépensé je
dis pas qu'il faut annuler absolument
tous les événements mais en tout cas ça
tombe d'entre eux qui nous permettent
évidemment de mobiliser les forces
pendant qu'ils sont là ils ne sont pas
ailleurs ce qui me permet de dire aux
élus d'ailleurs qu'il n'y aura pas de
CRS des plages cette année-là je suis
celui qui a maintenu les CRS des puisque
il était prévu de les supprimer donc je
suis très attaché à leur présence sur
les plages de France mais j'ai déjà
prévenu les élus que il pouvait les
forces de police bien sûr et gendarmerie
mais qui n'y aurait pas de CRS des
plages en 2024 puisqu'ils seront
mobilisés ces restes des plages c'est
rien d'autre que des CRS qui font leur
travail de de CRS si je veux dire le
reste de l'année et qui sécurise les
plages pendant la période estivale
louant ainsi un lien police population
mais il est certain que nous ne pourrons
pas le faire puisque si nous regardons
littéralement ce qu'il nous faudrait en
ufm ce serait trois sens du FM
c'est-à-dire à peu près deux fois plus
que ce que nous allons créer après la
loterie donc comme cette strictement
impossible on aura l'occasion
d'expliquer comment j'arrive à mes 300
ufm sans les créer mais ça veut dire que
voilà il y a des symptômes d'événements
comme ça qu'on utilise d'été et qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas là en 2024
chacun le comprendra j'ai déjà annoncé
au policiers au gendarmes que sauf très
rare exception ils n'auront pas de congé
pendant le mois de juin juillet juin
juillet début août on les annonce dès
maintenant
et ça vaut pour le gardien de la paix
comme jusqu'au ministre de l'Intérieur
bien évidemment et donc à tous les
étages des états majors voilà j'ai
moi-même rappelé ce matin d'ailleurs à
mes directeurs que le chef c'était celui
qui montre l'exemple et donc il or
exception et qui peut se comprendre pour
des raisons de d'accompagnement social
de maladie particulière il peut pas y
avoir de congés pendant ces périodes au
ministère de l'intérieur ce qui va nous
permettre d'avoir évidemment beaucoup
plus de présence de voies publiques ça
veut pas dire qu'il y aura pas de congés
du tout ça veut dire qu'ils seront juste
décalés et que on partira soit avant
soit après c'est c'est ces événements
évidemment l'intégralité des états major
je pense à la DGSI pour le terrorisme on
aura l'occasion peut-être d'en reparler
à la ddgène et à la DGPN comme à l'ATP
de de d'hyper présence bien en amont et
bien sûr nous avons besoin vous le savez
de 25000 agents de sécurité privée pour
pouvoir être au rendez-vous de ce grand
événement
alors si je prends l'exemple d'un
endroit particulier qui est sans doute
le plus difficile le plus
[Musique]
le défi le plus important c'est celui de
la cérémonie d'ouverture quel lieu donc
le 26 juillet 2024 au cœur de l'été où
nous devons assurer la sécurité à Paris
de 100000 spectateurs qui paieront des
billets pour aller dans les kebabs
c'est-à-dire les quais en bas de la
Seine où il y aura des facilitises comme
on dit également en chimie donc c'est à
dire des endroits où on peut se
restaurer donc il y a aussi toute une
question autour de la sécurité incendie
ou évidemment des gens vont faire des
malaises il y aura évidemment un certain
temps de difficultés personnelles on est
près de l'eau donc il y a de brigades
fluviale enfin bref vous voyez bien ce
que c'est que organiser des guinguettes
mais vous l'imaginez le canal de
Tourcoing mais là c'est le canal de
Paris donc c'est un peu plus grand un
petit peu plus grand pas beaucoup plus
mais un petit peu plus grand avec 100
000 spectateurs payants qui vont qui
vont payer des billets d'air assez cher
donc ils vont vouloir une expérience
client comme on dit très importante la
sécurité fait évidemment partie sur les
points hauts c'est à dire tous ceux qui
ne font pas partie des kebabs pardon de
cette autologie c'est 500 000 personnes
qui pour regarder ce qui se passe sur la
scène puisque le principe de la c'est
une ouverture c'est que sur des barges
sur des bateaux les équipes entrecoupées
si je l'ai bien compris mais la
programmation culturelle de la
du comité organisation n'est pas encore
claire donc ça c'est à peu près du mise
à l'intérieur c'est qu'il organise il
sait à peu près ce qu'on va faire pour
les Jeux olympiques mais j'ai compris
que la tête un feu d'artifice à tour
Eiffel mais c'est pas certain bon faut
sécuriser un feu d'artifice c'est voilà
il y aura du monde pas évident j'ai
compris qu'il y aurait peut-être des
concerts en même temps j'ai compris
aussi qu'il y aurait peut-être des des
bateaux avec peut-être aussi des
concerts dessus donc je vous avoue
parfois je demande un peu le cahier des
charges qu'on qu'on va me donner bon
mais donc voilà pour l'instant j'ai
compris qu'il y avait surtout des
bateaux avec des équipes qui se
présentaient au spectateur et et donc
les gens vont regarder et peut-être même
ils vont regarder avec des fans zones
soit directement près de la scène avec
des écrans géants soit un peu en recul
dans d'autres coins de Paris
là j'attends un petit retour
effectivement de la Mairie de Paris
aussi et de et du comité d'organisation
voir dans toute la France en banlieue
bien sûr et dans toute la France il faut
protéger ses Fan Zone parce qu'il
s'agirait pas que tout soit très protégé
de Paris et que ce soit qu'un attentat a
eu lieu dans une fan zone dans le
Val-d'Oise ou que les actes de
délinquance très graves et lieu dans le
nord de la France ou dans le sud donc en
tout cas si je regarde juste la
cérémonie d'ouverture stricto sensu nous
sommes à 100.000 en bas 500 000
spectateurs en haut c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a 600000 personnes dans l'hypersens de
Paris le long de la Seine avec des
normes problèmes d'ordre public si
jamais les choses se passaient
évidemment mal puisque chacun va
constater que voilà en amont et en aval
nous avons d'énormes endroits ça va être
absolument magnifique bien évidemment
qui vont être un rendez-vous avec des
endroits pas très faciles à sécuriser en
tant que tel des ponts et des
passerelles des quais pour ceux qui
connaissent ces quatre scènes je pense
que tout le monde les connaît ici voilà
qui parfois sont large parfois sont plus
étroits avec évidemment une île ou deux
îles même plutôt en plein en plein
milieu qu'il faut sécuriser des gens qui
habitent qui vont pouvoir rentrer chez
eux une personne peut faire une crise
cardiaque dans ses habitations comment
on y accède voilà et puis la tribune
officiel qui est donc au pied de la Tour
Eiffel avec
une très grande proportion de chef
d'État qui demande aussi un certain
nombre de Sécurité de Transport de
voyage bien évidemment donc c'est
évidemment pour nous un grand grand défi
que cette série d'ouverture nous y
travaillons beaucoup avec notamment le
préfet de police que j'ai changé
directement de ce sujet en lien avec la
Mairie de Paris bien sûr et le comité
d'organisation c'est à dire que ce
jour-là il y aura 35000 forces de
l'ordre à Paris
donc vous voyez de quoi on
est en train de parler et nous
souhaitons nous alors je dis nous
souhaitons parce que pour l'instant ce
n'est pas encore totalement finalisé
mais je suis sûr qu'on trouvera un
gentleman argument c'est la billetterie
gratuite parce qu'en fait pour l'instant
ce qui n'est pas prévu que les gens qui
vont dans le quai haut et 500 000
puissent être compté
puisque spontanément les gens pourraient
venir et voilà ne serait-ce que pour
c'est un ERP en
en Seine vivante ces personnes nous nous
souhaitons qu'il y a une billetterie une
billetterie c'est l'ouvert pardon une
billetterie gratuite obligatoire pour
qu'on puisse compter ces personnes bien
évidemment les répartir un peu partout
en imaginant des zones de répartition
tout à fait imaginer un site internet ou
des endroits en lien avec les mairies
par exemple qui permettent de distribuer
cette billetterie gratuite c'est juste
pour que les gens puissent se répartir
avec des plans des numéros de téléphone
des endroits évidemment pour ce pour se
retrouver puis qu'on puisse assurer
cette sécurité sachant qu'on ne peut pas
accéder au kebab sans passer par les Keo
donc les les organisateurs on aura
l'occasion de parler de qui est
responsable de quoi les organisateurs
ils doivent pouvoir à la fois laisser
passer des spectateurs qui vont avoir
une expérience gratuite sur les 500 000
en hauteur voir choisir d'aller dans les
concerts mis en place par l'organisation
et la ville de Paris soit rentré chez
eux ce qui est tout à fait légitime
quand on habitera Paris à ce moment là
où aller dans les kebabs pour lesquels
on aura payé parfois quelques milliers
d'euros un billet et donc il s'agira de
distinguer sans mauvais organisations ce
point de vue ce sera évidemment
concentré d'ailleurs en quelques heures
on peut imaginer que les gens arrivent
très tôt d'ailleurs sur ce site et qu'il
faudra
la sécurité c'est pas que la sécurité au
sens délinquance du terme c'est aussi
une sécurité civile il faudra
accompagner de ces personnes qui auront
besoin de facilité pour aller aux
toilettes qui auront des bobos bien
évidemment des enfants des personnes
plus âgées des personnes qui parlent pas
tous français et je regrette que tous
les policiers de France parlent pas
japonais et et anglais chinois mais
voilà il va falloir aussi qu'on soit
assez malin pour d'abord former une
partie des personnes
correspondre que chacun est à une offre
de service public évidemment sur le
territoire national
on doit bien sûr mobiliser ce jour là
3000 agents de sécurité privée et c'est
pas pas une insulte que de dire que il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui assez d'agents de
sécurité privée puisque par ailleurs
nous avons et je crois bien fait tous
ensemble augmenter les critères de
sécurité des agents de sécurité
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler mais il
y a évidemment une gageure ici les
polices municipales évidemment ont
associés elles sont pas responsables de
ce qui se passe en termes de sécurité
mais enfin sont associés moi je salue
l'objectif de la mère de Paris de
d'aller vers 3000 recrutements de sa
police municipale à l'horizon 2024 je
sais que préfet de policier travaille
avec elle mais c'est sûr que moins il y
aura de policiers municipaux plus faudra
agent de sécurité privée moi il y aura
l'agence sécurité privée plus ça prendra
sur la police et la gendarmerie et c'est
pas le travail de l'armée que de le
faire j'ai parfois entendu dire qu'on a
qu'à envoyer l'armée mais l'armée c'est
pas son travail de faire ce travail là
elle ne le sait pas elle ne le sait pas
le faire l'armée va nous aider sur plein
de sujets mais pas sur celui-ci il faut
donc que chacun fasse sa part du métier
agent de sécurité privée
[Musique]
alors ça c'est évidemment les sujets
d'organisation et il y a le sujet
concomitant qui est celui de la zéro
délinquance sur l'ensemble des sites
mais surtout sur l'ensemble des lieux
des communes qui accueillent la Coupe du
monde de rugby et les Jeux Olympiques
et donc ce que j'ai demandé c'est qu'à
partir de cet hiver nous mettions en
place dans chacune des préfectures mais
singulièrement à la préfecture de police
à Paris et en scène Saint-Denis
notamment mais pas que tous les
départements sont concernés des
opérations antidélinquance grandeur
nature pour dès maintenant
démanteler la délinquance des sites que
nous pouvons connaître y compris dans un
talent très large pour moi l'interlande
de Saint-Denis c'est la
Seine-Saint-Denis donc c'est toute la
Seine-Saint-Denis est concerné et donc
nous allons là aussi je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de le dire mais lancer 5500
opérations antidélingquence à partir
donc dans les jours qui viennent les
premières arrivent pour tout vous dire
la semaine prochaine à Paris
d'autres 1500 en Île-de-France de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit de pouvoir harceler
nettoyer il n'y a pas d'autres mots la
délinquance par tous les moyens que nous
pouvons mettre en place bien sûr une
présence très très forte de la police et
de la gendarmerie dans la lutte contre
les points de l'île les vols de véhicule
les vols d'appropriation comme on dit
dans la dans la prestationale mais aussi
utiliser la police administrative et on
sait tous que pour ceux qui ont dirigé
des exécutifs locaux notamment des
mairies on met du temps à faire fermer
des sites par la police administrative
parce que on n'utilise pas toujours
l'ensemble des moyens de contrôle et
surtout quand on les obtient il y a des
recours l'autorité préfectorale met du
temps le maire met du temps à signer
bref ça met quelques mois avant
d'arriver à la fermeture de tel commerce
qui ne respectaient aucune règle de tel
autre qui vendait des choses interdites
d'un logement insalubre dont on sait
qu'il était le nourricière d'une drogue
d'inurbanisme qui était mal organisé et
donc j'ai demandé à chacun des préfets
d'utiliser les contrôles vétérinaires
les contrôles du commentaires de compte
public a commencé par la Direction
générale des défuntances publiques ici
prêtent et je vous remercie des des
sujets que peut faire évidemment les
systèmes comme la cause et puis bien sûr
le travail de police du maire donc
partiellement on en parle avec Monsieur
maire de Saint-Denis mais on va parler
avec tous les maires que je recevrai
individuellement de comment on utilise
le pouvoir d'urbanisme comme on l'a fait
d'ailleurs dans la fermeture d'un
syndrome de culte pour d'autres raisons
quand on arrive pas à l'obtenir dans le
temps de la police judiciaire puisque
évidemment tout ça est un peu long
parfois et que là il s'agit pas de
traîner en longueur donc ces opérations
antidélinquance doivent mener au fait
que bien en amont de la communion de
rugby mais surtout bien amont des Jeux
Olympiques si je regarde les Jeux
Olympiques on a un an et demi de
harcèlement de nettoyage de chacun de
ces endroits pour que l'ensemble des
spectateurs mais aussi des habitants ce
sera un héritage des Jeux Olympiques si
je veux dire si on arrive à rendre comme
héritage que on a baissé extrêmement
fortement la
[Musique]
élus je regarde le président de la
commission des lois qui est là je ne
peux pas cette un problème qu'elle mise
intérieure imposé au maire sauf à Paris
puisque Paris c'est une compétence
préfecture de police la compétence qui
lui est propre qui est celle avec son
conseil municipal c'est caméra
vidéoprotection parce que législateur a
voulu je soumets ça votre sagacité
puisque là quand on accueille les Jeux
Olympiques coupe du monde de rugby au
bout d'un moment je le dis devant votre
commission parce que je vais m'expliquer
de ce qui s'est passé au Stade de France
il y a des moments où on est on est un
peu on est un peu bloqué devant la
compétence mais en même temps je
respecte évidemment l'article 72 de la
Constitution telle que législateur a
voulu créer en tout cas pour Paris pour
Marseille pour la Seine-Saint-Denis en
général je peux vous avouer que c'est
quelque soit les bords politiques des
élus nous le faisons je crois en bonne
intelligence et s'il faut rajouter des
moyens d'ailleurs ne les ne les ne les
rajouterons
j'ai pas entendu
je veux évidemment dire qu'on a par
ailleurs un gros sujet de renforcement
des des de la motivation ou en tout cas
de l'ouverture à l'embauche par exemple
de sécurité privée qui ont fait un
premier étape je trouve positive en
acceptant l'augmentation des
rémunérations de leur salarié ça c'était
un point très important vous avez vu
qu'il y avait un blocage particulier on
aura l'occasion dans d'en parler si vous
le souhaitez en tout cas les Pôle Emploi
les préfectures et notamment monsieur
préfet de la région Île-de-France
particulièrement mobilisée pour appeler
un par un c'est ce qui se passe à ce
moment même toutes les personnes qui
cherchent un emploi et qui peuvent en
trouver un très facilement dans la
sécurité privée l'état paye la formation
ce qu'on a fait évidemment dans aucun
autre métier pour Pôle emploi
la lutte contre le terrorisme évidemment
pour nous c'est c'est une menace
extrêmement présente si quelqu'un veut
frapper notre sol c'est peut-être mieux
pour lui de le faire devant 4 milliards
de téléspectateurs donc évidemment c'est
la menace qui est déjà très élevée sera
très très élevé pour la communion de
rugby est très très élevé pour les Jeux
Olympiques cette menace elle peut
prendre diverses
évidemment formes ça peut être le
commando armé tel que nous l'avons connu
au Bataclan ça peut être évidemment la
menace endogène la personne qui prend le
couteau et qui passe lui-même à l'acte
ça peut être des personnes connues des
personnes inconnues je vous rappelle que
d'ailleurs parmi les attentats
90% des attentats que nous avons connu
dans les 10 derniers n'étaient pas
connus des services de renseignement
donc ça pose mais évidemment une
question de suivi mais il y a quand même
des gens que nous connaissons et donc
j'ai demandé au directeur général de la
Sécurité intérieure de mobiliser
l'intégralité des effectifs de la DGSI y
compris ceux qui font autre chose
d'habitude que de la lutte contre le
terrorisme des GSI fait plein de choses
et fait du contretempionnage de
mobiliser évidemment dans cette période
très précise ces agents sur le suivi
alors il y a des suivis des personnes
que nous connaissons comme étant
radicalisés ou comme étant dangereuses
que soient islamiste ultra droite ultra
gauche malheureusement la menace est
très très large
évidemment par des outils administratifs
ou judiciaires on a eu ce débat 150 fois
sur les mycas par exemple mais aussi
pour être très fort en renseignement
bien en amont pour pouvoir judiciariser
à quelques temps de ces événements pour
pouvoir mieux maîtriser les personnes
qui sont les plus dangereuses sur le sol
national nous avons énormément de
besoins de détection une exploitation de
données on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
ce qui est certain c'est que nous devons
absolument travailler pas simplement
avec le DGSI mais l'ensemble des
services de renseignement avec les
autres ministères DGSE qui dépend du
ministre des Armées par exemple ou
Tracfin qui dépend du ministre des
comptes publics j'ai demandé que la DGSI
avec les services de renseignement et
d'abord une doctrine spécifique de lutte
contre le terrorisme on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler si vous le souhaitez
peut-être dans un cadre un peu un peu
moins public ou un peu différent
voilà ce que je veux dire en quelques
mots Messieurs les Présidents vous aurez
compris que c'est un défi très très
important je veux dire que dans le
rapport que vous avez commis et fait
voter sur les 15 de mémoire proposition
il y en a une que nous n'avons pas suivi
mais je pense lui expliquer lorsqu'on
s'était vu c'était sur la digeste et la
Diop mais que les 14 autres je suis en
mesure de vous les documenter son suivi
soit parce qu'elles sont suivies au sens
c'est fait dans la loopy ou en dehors de
la loterie soit parce qu'elles seront
suivies demain puisque il y aura une loi
Jeux Olympiques et donc des mesures sont
en ce moment en discussion mais
j'imagine que des questions et notamment
des mesures de sécurité de grands
événements bien évidemment soit il
s'agit de mesure de doctrine ce que j'ai
déjà mis en place avec le nouveau préfet
de police en ce qui concerne des
événements je pense que ce qui devrait
nous intéresser quand même c'est quand
même la non comparaison malgré tout
entre le football et le reste des sports
je prends un exemple qui va si au
Parisien pour ce soir mais Maccabi Haïfa
PSG c'est 10 unités de force mobile plus
assez ensuite pour un match
j'ai connu il y a trois semaines un
match de National 2 à Versailles avec
trois unités de force mobile voilà ce
que fait mes intérieurs aujourd'hui il
met trois unités de CRS pour un match de
national de gtr8 de football dans des
coins de la banlieue parisienne il y a
15 ans je n'ai pas tout à fait certain
que c'était même s'il y avait de la
violence pareil et je ne connaissais
malheureusement que dans le football on
pourrait multiplier les exemples c'est
évidemment le match de Nice qui s'est
déroulée pas très longtemps mais je de
Marseille donc voilà donc je crois que
les instances du football réfléchissent
aujourd'hui avec un misé sport à ce
qu'on peut faire pour améliorer le
supporterisme voilà il faut qu'on le
fasse bien évidemment je veux juste
mettre à votre sagacité que pour un
match au Parc des Princes dont on
connaît tous
à la fois la sécurisation et d'habitude
c'est des unités de force moyen pour un
seul match mais fort heureusement si
j'ose dire tous les matchs tous les les
moments de sport des Jeux Olympiques ne
correspondent pas des matchs de football
de haut niveau tels que ça donc la
comparaison ne vaut pas toujours raison
bien merci Monsieur ministre pour ces
informations déjà très précises je
j'indique à mes collègues que nous
devons terminer à 18h précises puisqu'il
y a une autre réunion qui se suit à 18h
je vais nous allons vous passer avec le
président du fait la parole je voudrais
juste commencer par une première
question monsieur le
ministre dans son livre paru récemment
Didier l'allemand dit je le cite pour le
moment j'observe que les JO se préparent
comme la finale du Stade de France
l'interrogation reste la même qui est
responsable qui fait quoi alors pour
être très honnête son interview je crois
date de fin juillet donc entre fin
juillet aujourd'hui les choses ont
probablement évolué mais ma question
sera simple est-ce que la chaîne de
commandement sous votre autorité mais
est-ce que la chaîne de commandement a
été précisé notamment entre préfet de
police et digeste dijob parce qu'on sait
que c'est une des difficultés
rencontrées lors de la finale de la
Champions League et est-ce que le rôle
des préfets départements est également
été précisé
vous citez les grands auteurs monsieur
le Président j'en suis heureux
le préfet de police allemand a raison de
dire que et je pense que vous l'avez
souligné vous-même que le nom de du
grand événement
fait que quoi qu'il arrive de toute
façon on se retourne vers l'état même si
ce n'est pas une compétence en tant que
telle de l'État parce qu'il aurait dû
mettre l'épée dans les reins au moment
de la compétition soit parce qu'il a mal
géré ensuite ce qui est sûr c'est que ce
problème se pose pas pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby et des Jeux Olympiques
puisque j'ai une lettre du Premier
ministre Valls encore une fois de 2016
qui
me nomme comme coordonnateur suprême
c'est lui-même qui écrit suprême donc ça
ça m'impressionne beaucoup pour
l'organisation de la sécurité de ces
grands événements coupe du monde de
rugby Jeux Olympiques donc on sait qui
est le responsable d'un point de vue de
la sécurité de la voie publique et d'un
produit de la sécurité d'ordre public
ensuite il est certain que ce qui se
passe en organisation au sens
vous êtes dans un stade avec votre
billet pour rentrer dans la compétition
c'est le Comité olympique donc il faut
bien distinguer les choses mais c'est
pas le même type de sécurité en tant que
tel notamment se poser la question de la
billetterie bon voilà je le regarde
évidemment ça m'intéresse mais c'est un
sujet de compétence de l'organisateur
c'est lui qui touche l'argent tout
simplement après on a un dernier sujet à
comprendre je l'ai évoqué en terme
diplomatique parce que j'ai des
relations je crois franchi cordiales
avec la mère de Paris c'est qui est
responsable de l'ensemble des zones de
la cérémonie d'ouverture et notamment si
on comprend qu'il est responsable des
kebabs puisque il y a un organisateur
qui touche d'ailleurs de l'argent
puisqu'il y a des billets
personne n'est pour l'instant a priori
responsable des KO
c'est à dire c'est spectateurs gratuits
et est-ce que c'est un ERP assez ouvert
au sens littéral du terme à laquelle
l'état donne une autorisation ou est-ce
qu'on part du principe que c'est par
nature l'état puisque en plus on est à
Paris c'est à dire sous l'autorité du
préfet de police et pas de n'importe
quelle mer si vous me permettez cette
expression et là moi je plaide pour deux
choses je plaide pour que 1 ce soit
évidemment une billetterie gratuite et
que deux pour par facilité ce soit
l'état qui soit responsable mais si
l'État est responsable de sécurité il
est responsable de l'organisation c'est
à dire qu'on peut si on a envie de
mettre des écrans géants ici une ouvrir
une voirie là faire tel type de
facilities ce sera l'État qui décidera
et pas la ville de Paris donc je crois
qu'on est en discussion pour tout vous
dire avec la mère de Paris on va
terminer ça dans les prochains jours on
n'est pas non plus en perte de vitesse
parce qu'on prépare bien les Jeux
olympiques de Paris avec sérieux
c'est des questions vous l'avez vu
immense qui se pose à nous d'ici la fin
de l'année je pense qu'on sera mis et je
pense qu'il faudra l'écrire avec la
Ville de Paris et le comité
d'organisation qui est responsable des
Keo qui est responsable de la série
d'ouverture en amont il y a pas il y a
pas d'autres mots voilà moi je pense que
comme à la fin si ça se passe bien tout
le monde dira c'est formidable
organisateur était très bon ça se passe
mal quand on dira que fait maison
intérieur je préfère avoir la
responsabilité de me faire engueuler si
je suis vraiment responsable parce que
le pire c'est de se faire engueuler
quand on n'est pas responsable ça c'est
vraiment la pire des situations pour un
responsable quel qu'il soit donc c'est
la proposition qu'on a faite à la mère
de Paris en tout cas que le préfet de
police a fait la mer de Paris on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler je verrai
madame midalgo à qui je vais solliciter
un rendez-vous très très prochainement
une fois que j'aurai eu les derniers
rapports complets de l'ensemble des
forces dans les départements et dans le
préfet de police donc pour répondre à
votre question c'est très différent de
la coupe de la finale de la Ligue des
champions au point près des Keo de la
cérémonie d'ouverture mais qui est
important et qu'on va régler
merci Monsieur le Ministre de la parole
à Monsieur Louis qui avait puis monsieur
Assouline ensuite et puis après Madame
Brigitte l'herbier puis monsieur Claude
kerbe oui monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre j'avais une question qui
monsieur ministre
boucle avec le début de votre
intervention et les articulations à
domicile de la défense sur les armées
sur notamment la question de l'opération
sentinelle le niveau le niveau de
vigilance attentat est toujours très
élevé dans notre pays il le sera
fortiori avec l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques dans le cadre évidemment de
vos attributions et j'imagine aussi de
la confidentialité d'un certain nombre
de choses mais que pouvez nous dire de
plus sur l'articulation qu'il y aura
entre les services de sécurité
intérieure et les forces qui dépendent
des armées et sur quelle mission
notamment qui se rapproche des missions
d'Orbe publique vous entendez que les
armées soient associées merci Monsieur
Assouline
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
si on veut faire un lien bon on a une
audition vous aviez été très très vous
avez développé en détail des choses au
moment de
du bilan de ce qui s'était passé au
Stade de France maintenant on est en
amont et on tire les leçons et on vous a
à nouveau avec un exposé tout à fait
important mais
j'aimerais avoir vos réponses sur de où
on est parti avec l'histoire du Stade de
France il y avait un problème de
coordination et de responsabilité vous
n'avez répondu que partiellement vous
dites que vous pouvez pas encore
répondre puis c'est une négociation mais
est-ce que vous pouvez quand même nous
répondre sur le fait que la clarté
absolue de qui décide quoi
indépendamment de la chaîne il y a une
personne qui décide
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le dire
parce que ça commence par là
vu l'ampleur de ce qui est prévu la
deuxième chose c'était
avait été discuté la doctrine
de maintien de l'ordre dans des
situations où il y a une foule une foule
en plus qui vient pour quelque chose de
festif et des incidences produisent dans
cette foule est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur quoi vous travaillez pour
quelle est la réponse des forces de
l'ordre dans ce contexte au vu de ce qui
s'est passé au Stade de France et au vu
de ce qui est attendu comme comme foule
comme masse là
ensuite avait été évoqué à ce moment-là
quelque chose qui m'avait déjà
interpellé on s'était dit c'est en
milieu fermé et il y a eu des gros
incidents on va être dans quelque chose
qui s'étale sur 6 km en bord de Seine
et j'avais posé la question quel est
votre évaluation de ceux qui vont venir
puisque c'est ouvert
on m'avait déjà dit 600 000 j'avais posé
la question sur quelle base vous
prévoyez 600 000 parce que quand il y a
un des trucs qui ressemble c'est il y a
eu une Jubilée de la reine peut-être
maintenant l'enterrement c'est sur une
grande étendue dans l'ombre avec une
foule immense qui vient et qui est gérée
et on dit que c'est un million deux
donc j'insiste parce que un des éléments
clés sur le Stade de France c'est la la
c'est l'anticipation et 600 000 et 1
million deux c'est juste le double donc
non mais c'est important parce que ce
que vous vous continuez à réfléchir
qu'on a un truc maîtrisé comme si on est
invité 600 000 personnes en réalité il y
a 100 000 personnes qui sont invitées
vous prévoyez qu'il y en a 500 000 de
plus qui vont venir mais voilà on a
besoin de réponses sur
quels sont les éléments plus précis quel
est le niveau de réactivité que vous
aurez y compris à l'instant T si vos
prévisions étaient mauvaises parce que
sinon l'ensemble du système est
problématique je je finis on vous
demandant en vous demandant
quelque chose de précis parce que
s'il y a 30 000 forces de l'or 35000 etc
mais c'est sur un mois
on a vécu un moment où des forces de
l'ordre ont été mobilisées sur le long
terme en situation de crise
notamment la crise des gilets jaunes etc
on a tous remarqué que l'utilisation sur
un temps donné des forces de l'ordre
tout le temps il y avait un problème de
fatigue il y avait un problème de
renouvellement qu'est-ce qui est
anticipé pour pour prévenir ce merci
beaucoup chers collègues madame
l'herbier oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre nombreux sites à
protéger
difficile de tout imaginer ça c'est sûr
mais les JO sont tellement un magnifique
une magnifique vitrine pour notre pays
qu'il faut absolument que tout se passe
à merveille alors vous avez parlé des
transports en commun donc le train avion
métro tout ça à Paris il y a vraiment
il y a des lieux de haut risque dans les
transports en commun alors j'aimerais
attirer votre attention sur
sur les problèmes pouvant arriver à la
gare du Nord la gare du Nord est
surchargée continuellement
on constate tout le temps des retards de
train des trains nuls etc des
débordements peuvent provoquer des
marées humaines comme dans beaucoup
d'autres regards mais le problème de la
Gare du Nord c'est
il va y avoir un flux de voyageurs
extraordinaire en plus puisque on aura
les Eurostars les Thalys en provenant
des royaumesnil des Pays-Bas de Belgique
d'Allemagne
nombre de personnes en plus qui vont
arriver dans ces gains pour assister aux
épreuves ou pour faire du tourisme à
cette occasion les chauffeurs de taxi
déjà aujourd'hui nous alerte de la
difficulté d'accéder
justement à la gare du Nord et comme
d'autres gars
le tout dans un dans un milieu quand
même
ou règne l'insécurité actuelle de jour
comme de nuit alors ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est
comment se se passe les concertations
avec vos autres
vos autres collègues ministres le
ministre des Transports il y a eu
beaucoup de ministre de transport qui
ont essayé de de d'essayer de trouver de
à répondre au problème à la
problématique des voyageurs en surnombre
le ministre des Transports actuels
travaille-t-il en amont justement pour
vous épauler dans ces préparatifs parce
que je pense que le ministre de
l'Intérieur certes à la responsabilité
mais vous parliez tout à l'heure de de
partage de responsabilité les autres
ministres j'aimerais bien savoir si à
quelle hauteur il partage aussi votre
responsabilité en matière de préparation
de ces Jeux Olympiques merci madame
monsieur Claude Kern et merci monsieur
le Président alors merci monsieur le
ministre pour cette présentation et je
veux dire que nous attendons avec
impatience la loi sur les
vous avez parlé reparlé de la violence
dans les stades c'est vrai que ça
demeure une préoccupation après les
débordements qu'on a observé ces
derniers mois et nous avons eu
l'occasion d'auditionner récemment
l'ambassadeur du Japon en France
concernant la sécurité des Jeux de Tokyo
il nous a indiqué que les autorités
avaient largement recourus à la
reconnaissance faciale et nous a
conseillé de faire de même est-ce que la
France est prête à employer des
technologies qui ont fait leurs preuves
au Japon
vous avez parlé des
agents de sécurité privée puisque il en
faut 25000 d'ailleurs la Cour des
comptes s'inquiète des fragilités
structurelles du secteur de la sécurité
privée et de leur impact sur les JO
on connaît les tensions qui pèsent sur
cette profession comment envisagez-vous
d'augmenter le nombre de recrutement
dans ce secteur notamment via la
formation afin de disposer du nombre
d'agents nécessaires pour assurer la
sécurité lors des JO et il est
naturellement fondamental d'établir
clairement le rôle et les
responsabilités de chacun et d'organiser
les flux importants
nous avons également pu nous rendre
compte je reviens pas sur la cyber
puisque vous en avez parlé et que c'est
encore en gestation mais
avec les événements au Stade de France
que la sécurisation de la billetterie de
la je reviens est un enjeu
particulièrement important et nous avons
en France des Champions en la matière
qui proposent une solution de
billetterie sécurisée fonctionnant sur
la blockchain je parlais de tes os
notamment et qui correspond à la récente
recommandation du délégué
interministériel au jeu quel où en est
votre réflexion sur ces solutions et le
cas échéant pouvez-vous nous garantir la
participation de nos entreprises
françaises particulièrement innovantes
et compétitive à ce process et je ne
vais pas embrayer sur la question des
flux lors des transports puisque ça a
été évoqué et on vous remercie
la parole au ministre avant de donner la
parole à d'autres collègues ensuite
pour répondre à Monsieur Hervé sur le
myssa des armées si on est en train d'y
travailler donc je voudrais de
près arbitrer mais moi je ne suis pas
pour que le ministère des armées ou que
les armées en dehors de sentinelles
parce que sentinelle c'est une opération
c'est à dire classique de lutte contre
le terrorisme de prévention qui mérite
évidemment d'être présente lors des Jeux
olympiques que la Coupe du monde de
rugby mais le travail du ministère des
armées c'est pas utilisé des militaires
pour faire le travail des agents de
sécurité privée ou des policiers des
gendarmes donc c'est pas la demande du
ministre de l'intérieur mais les drones
c'est déjà un gros sujet la surveillance
aérienne de notre pays c'est un énorme
sujet vous parliez des fume à la
sénatrice vous allez mais je pense au
flux des aéroports c'est aussi un sujet
comme on accueille autant de personnes
dans les aéroports quand on sait comment
parfois on les accueille c'est aussi un
sujet
et il y a aussi peut-être ici ou là un
certain nombre de sujets qui peuvent
votre militaire bon j'ouvre une option
et je mets du conditionnel pour ceux qui
m'écoutent
garder les bateaux en amont de la
cérémonie voilà peut-être que ce genre
de choses ça peut être quelque chose qui
peut se trouver dans un endroit
militaire ou en lien avec des militaire
mais en tout cas ça ne peut être si je
veux dire que des choses comme cela je
n'imagine pas il faudrait que sentinelle
soit au maximum évidemment au moment de
la coupe du monde de rugby des Jeux
olympiques mais j'imagine pas de
substitution par exemple c'est pour ça
qu'on vous a proposé une loop me c'est
pour avoir des des effectifs qui
correspondent des nerfs merci en très
grande majorité nous les avons retrouvés
et de l'avoir ainsi compris mais je
pense que ça peut être intéressant
notamment sur les antidrone je dis au
président
qu'on est qu'on est à jouer une
explication devant vous parce que c'est
c'est la première fois vous savez à part
l'Élysée et encore et la place Bovo
puisque on est la chance d'avoir des
voisins
sympathiques et contre l'autorité mais à
part l'Élysée elle passe bobo il y a pas
de couverture anti-drone de notre de
notre nos sites
institutionnels ou de nos sites
sensibles voilà et donc on nous
découvrons
alors on a des pour le coup des
industriels qui travaillent très bien
avec des fusils antidrone des canons
anthydrone voilà on arrive à découvrir
sa zone de choses on arrive à arrêter
des drones qui viennent filmer mais la
question de savoir qu'est-ce qu'on fait
du drone qu'un explosif parce que le
drone qui est de filmer il est
neutralisé par l'onde et ensuite il peut
tomber par manque de batterie évidemment
je caricature pour que chacun comprenne
mais si un explosif sur lui s'il tombe
et qui tombe même si il évite le lieu
institutionnel qu'on veut lui éviter il
peut exploser quand même donc voilà on a
tout un travail très important à faire
et notamment avec nos camarades de nos
camarades militaires
sur la les questions de Monsieur
Assouline bon qui décide de quoi bah
c'est assez simple
c'est moi qui suis responsable de la
sécurité des Jeux Olympiques en dehors
des stades en dehors des lieux de
compétition donc c'est mises à
l'intérieur et à Paris je l'ai confié
uniquement au préfet de police
donc c'est pas le dijob
c'est pas les préfets de département de
grandes couronnes puisque j'aurai une
disposition dans la loi olympique que je
pousse qui est que le pendant le temps
des Jeux Olympiques pendant le temps des
Jeux Olympiques le préfet de police va
préférer en chef de la sécurité de
l'ensemble de la grande couronne
parisienne y compris des grandes
départements d'Île-de-France notamment
pour des réseaux de transport et pour
les aéroports parce que on voit bien
qu'il y a des petits tuilages compliqués
parfois alors ce qui peuvent se vivre
dans la vie de tous les jours de la PP
ou la grande couronne mais dans un
moment de crise qui se passe solide
difficilement d'ailleurs j'encourage la
RATP la SNCF de se mettre aussi d'accord
sur les tuilages puisque on va bien vu
que l'un des problèmes de Stade de
France pour parler d'expérience c'était
aussi qu'est-ce qui relevait RATP
qu'est-ce SNCF moi j'ai résolu le
problème c'est le pépé qui s'occupe de
toute la grande couronne et la petite
couronne et de Paris et donc de moi bien
évidemment vous avez raison mais moi je
n'ai qu'un interlocuteur c'est préfet de
police
ça c'est le premier point et les préfets
de départements dans chacun de leur
département évidemment respectifs encore
une fois il faut que nous puissions
marquer noir sur blanc qui est
responsable de l'ensemble des axes et
des accès de la cérémonie d'ouverture ce
n'est pas faire offense à un aire de
Paris aux élus de Paris que leur dire
que c'est pas clair parce que évidemment
ce qu'on aimerait là c'est que sans
doute que nous soyons responsables de la
sécurité mais qu'on ne puisse pas donner
notre avis sur comment ça fonctionne le
RP si je suis et moi je c'est ce que je
souhaite être responsable de la sécurité
pour pouvoir répondre devant vous des
actes que nous prenons il faut
évidemment que on accepte tous que ces
ministères de l'Intérieur qui en
collaboration bien sûr avec les élus
mais à le dernier mot sur ce qu'il faut
ici mettre
caricature une friterie combien d'agents
de sécurité privée on met là voilà parce
que ça a des incidences énormes comme on
gérer les stations de métro comment on
gère les accès comment on gère la
titanisation comment on gère la
circulation bon bah c'est une question
très intéressante et passionnante
partout sur la
l'interlande y compris de la cérémonie
d'ouverture puisque la sommet
d'ouverture elle va assez loin si je
veux dire pour pouvoir prévoir les parce
que j'apprends va donc à votre deuxième
question
comment on est sûr qu'à 500 000 bon
d'abord 500
000 c'est ce qui a l'air d'être
disponible en tant d'hommes par espace
dans les endroits où on pourra regarder
la scène d'un ko donc si on prend tous
les espaces libres en dehors les espaces
qui bas et les endroits où on les arbres
ici le monument là c'est 500 000
personnes bon ce sera peut-être 550 000
ce sera peut-être 450 000 non mais c'est
pour ça que pour éviter le fait que ce
sera peut-être 800000 ou 900 000 nous on
veut une billetterie gratuite
c'est-à-dire que vous ne pourrez pas
accéder à un grand un grand endroit dans
Paris qui sera très large en tout cas ça
c'est ce que je propose si je suis en
responsabilité de l'ensemble de la
cérémonie d'ouverture et que les gens ne
pourront rentrer dans cet espace que à
partir du moment où ils ont une
billetterie gratuite habillée ce qui
nous permettra de faire une deuxième
demande dans la loi olympique que je
propose l'arbitrage de Madame la Premier
ministre c'est les périmètres cilts les
périmètre terreau que nous mettons en
place parfois on puisse les mettre pour
évidemment la cérémonie d'ouverture et
qu'on puisse faire un certain nombre de
contrôle qui sont exorbitants du droit
commun pour justement éviter que les
gens avec une arme rentrent avec faire
des contrôles d'identité pour savoir si
c'est tel ou telle personne parce que
dans l'immigré gratuite il y aura
l'identité des personnes ce sera très
intéressant pour nous évidemment pour
les passages aux fichiers pour regarder
s'il y a personne de personnes qui
réservant un billeterie sont très connus
des services de police évidemment ça
pose des tas de questions qui va qui
vont intéresser les parlementaires et et
l'organisateur mais c'est quand même
comme ça qu'on arrive à sécuriser
quelque chose de cette ampleur donc
l'idée c'est que si on est responsable
on est responsable y compris la
billetterie gratuite et donc on puisse
faire les premiers contrôles notamment
en fermant un nombre de stations de
métro et de réair très en amont pour
pouvoir faire des filtrage dans
l'ensemble de Paris plus on écarte si je
veux dire l'étoile de contrôle bah moi
il y a des gens qui s'agglutent et en
plus avec une énorme communication que
nous ferons qui consistera à dire ne
venez si vous n'avez pas de billes il y
aura toujours qui viendront bien
évidemment mais beaucoup moins que si on
dit c'est open venez tous vous pourrez
tous voir si jamais ouverture ce qui
pose des questions je l'ai dit en
introduction complémentaire avec
l'organisateur et la ville de Paris de
c'est quoi les autres événements qui ne
sont pas la série d'ouverture c'est
consensus mais qui sont le feu
d'artifice tout le monde a envie de le
voir donc ils sont les concerts que
cette maîtres ici ou là tel ou telle
organisateur bon voilà on discute de
tout ça avec Monsieur estanguay Madame
Madame la Maire de Paris sur
la question de la de
sur la question de la présence de de ces
policiers bon je vais quand même dire je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte de
des chiffres que j'ai annoncé en deux
policiers de gendarme genre ça n'a pas
d'équivalent
je crois 45000 policiers monsieur le
sénateur sur 12 km de la seconde
ouverture chez un petit calcul ça fait
3750 policiers gendarmes par kilomètre
ça fait 40 policiers gendarmes par 100
mètres
je crois que Marine n'aura jamais vu
autant de de policiers c'est à dire que
quand vous mettez 40 policiers gendarmes
les policiers gendarmes je vous rassure
tout de suite
mais je vous laisse de plus en plus vous
remarquer monsieur sénateur d'ailleurs
je vous entends moi parler du nombre
d'effectifs à Paris ce qui veut dire que
donc ça augmente puisque évidemment
c'est le principe c'est le principe non
non mais blague à part vraiment c'est
vraiment très important alors quand
alors pour la série l'ouverture à 45000
c'est vraiment pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture quand je dis en revanche que
nous avons un syndrome de policiers par
jour de c'est évidemment une moyenne et
c'est par deux vacations c'est à dire
qu'il y aura ceux qui commenceront le
matin bien ceux qui font l'après-midi
donc voilà et on a un énorme problème
enfin problème c'est pas un problème on
l'organise c'est qu'il faut loger toutes
ces personnes il faut les loger il faut
les nourrir il faut qu'ils aient leur
matériel et la question que je sais pas
si vous intéressera d'autres sujets que
mise à l'intérieur mais mais la question
de l'hébergement en Île-de-France est
une question
très importante pendant cette période
particulière voilà pour répondre à
Madame l'herbier ce qui me permet de
parler d'autres ministres effectivement
pardon
c'était le fait que on n'avait pas
forcément je l'ai déjà dit anticiper la
délinquance puisqu'il y avait une
succession de choses qui sont passées
qui ont mené au fait que les policiers
dans public sont allés dans le stade
en retard pour presser de tenir les
griffes je vais pas refaire le débat du
Stade de France mais du coup on laissait
assez ouvert une délinquance
d'appropriation contre les personnes et
par manque de policiers d'ailleurs vous
avez évoqué un concert mais il y a pas
eu de sujet de délinquance en tant que
tel à ce concert je suis
particulièrement intéressé vous
l'imaginer c'est un sujet de forcer la
billetterie comme vous l'avez dit parce
que désormais le nombre de policiers de
gendarmes qu'on met en Seine-Saint-Denis
et à Saint-Denis lors des événements
sportifs culturels font que je crois
qu'on est capable à la fois de maîtriser
l'ordre public le terreau la sécurité et
s'il y a un problème comment on fait
voilà je pense que ça c'est vraiment la
grande leçon qu'on a appris d'ailleurs
le préfet allemand le dit d'ailleurs
dans son livre si je ne m'abuse sur sur
ce point donc je pense que le sujet
encore une fois de Stade de France
évidemment une mauvaise réaction dans le
public parce que il y avait
précipitations manque d'effectif et
comment dirais-je changement de de
stratégie si je veux dire sans sans
coordination pendant déjà eu l'occasion
dans d'en parler ici moi je suis prêt à
venir on va laisser le ministre avancé
parce qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
questions monsieur l'insuline je lui
manque j'ai l'impression donc je suis
très heureux de lui répondre sur Madame
l'herbier sur la gare du Nord bon c'est
gare du Nord comme comme tous les comme
tous les lieux de transport à Paris moi
d'abord je suis très respectueux des
compétences de Madame la mère de Paris
qui en partie en partie à est très
jalouse de ses compétences de voir il ne
l'a pas elle ne les a pas toutes tes
compétences de voiries mais il en a un
parti et vous aurez constaté que quand
l'État en responsabilité ben nous avons
des désaccords avec la Ville de Paris
puisque nous avons fait un recours vous
l'avez fait elle a fait madame la mère
de Paris un recours sur notre
interdiction de sa petite isation et de
son projet sur lequel j'ai pas d'avis
d'opportunités ou esthétique mais je
constate que très bien administratif
nous a donné raison par ailleurs parce
que ce qui se passe par exemple auprès
de la pièce de la Tour Eiffel ce qui se
passe quai Branly ce qui se passe demain
peut-être à Saint-Germain ou après
n'importe de la chapelle a des
conséquences sur l'ensemble de la
circulation à Paris évidemment notamment
dans les reports de circulation pour les
interventions de police de de
d'ambulance mais aussi dans ce moment de
de vie donc dans le respect de chacune
de nos compétences nous essayons dans le
statut très particulier qui suit de
Paris avec le préfet de police d'être en
bonne intelligence avec même la mer même
si on a parfois effectivement des des
choses qu'ils ont tranchées dans les
tribunaux ce qui est sûr c'est que
Monsieur Beaune également parallèlement
à moi si j'ose dire un comité de
pilotage transport Jeux Olympiques dans
lequel je partis de mes équipes
participent d'ailleurs où j'irai
d'ailleurs faire un certain nombre de
réunion pour les gars mais aussi pour
les aéroports voilà et je pense que
Monsieur bonnet est tout à fait disposé
j'imagine par nature et par construction
mais à venir par exemple parce que les
enjeux de transport sont évidemment très
très importants sur la reconnaissance
faciale alors
je sais pas si ma question s'adressait à
moi ou à vos collègues monsieur le
sénateur ou un monsieur Hervé qui était
derrière moi je sais pas très bien qu'il
fallait non je
j'entends ce que j'entends ce que fait
le Japon il se trouve que le Japon il
s'assait sans doute bien passé parce que
il y avait d'ailleurs pas de spectateurs
sans doute à organiser
il fait du covid c'est pas propre au
moment japonais bien évidemment
je constate que le Qatar met en place sa
reconnaissance faciale dans le grand
événement qu'il est qu'il est concerne
je constate que je constate que la
candidature madame la sénatrice de la
ville de Paris comme de l'État à
l'époque prévoyait des voyants
technologiques que le Parlement nous
donne pas aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
c'est une vérité vrai c'est qu'on a été
au CIO on leur a dit voilà et on donne
pas les moyens juridiques pour le faire
voilà est-ce que moi je suis pour la
reconnaissance faciale la réponse est
non j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
pour dire que pour un événement
olympique comme pour tout événement je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille la
reconnaissance faciale après se poser la
question de quel type de société on veut
je crois qu'il faut aussi accepter de
par deux risques ce que vraiment
l'endroit où il n'y a aucun risque c'est
pas très rassurant d'un point de vue
démocratique donc je crois que on peut
avoir ce débat bon voilà évidemment il
est toujours difficile à tenir mais mais
la concentration sociale je ne suis pas
sûr que nous ayons aujourd'hui les
moyens de garantir que demain ils ne
sont pas utilisés autrement en revanche
que nous ayons des moyens de vidéos
titre intelligentes ou d'intelligence
artificielle appliquée à la vidéo oui ça
aujourd'hui la loi nous l'interdit et je
vais le demander je vais les demander à
Madame la Premier ministre comme
arbitrage j'ai demandé si jamais c'est
autorisé dans la loi olympique c'est
quoi la vidéo intelligente c'est quand
vous avez un mur d'image et que vous
recherchez une petite fille dans la
foule vous donnez pas la photo de la
petite fille que vous reconnaissez comme
étant la petite fille madame
mademoiselle X mais vous savez que la
petite fille elle est brune elle fait
1m20 et un t-shirt jaune et la vidéo
intelligente est capable de ressortir
toutes les vidéos toutes les petites
filles si vous recherchez un homme qui
se balade avec un couteau et qui a des
cheveux longs c'est pas pareil que de
recevoir que chercher monsieur Darmanin
vous recherchez un homme qui et donc les
caméras aident énormément à la décision
non j'ai pris cet exemple pour pas qu'il
attaque à domine bon d'ailleurs je ne
suis je ne suis pas grand voilà
et je n'ai pas de couteau
et je n'ai pas les cheveux longs c'est
pas pousser parce que c'est sinon la
police la police me donnerait des
papiers vu mes origines est-ce que vous
voulez dire c'est ça non mais j'ai eu
des contrôles d'identité très nombreux
quand j'étais jeune étudiant à Lille
madame la satrice non la question c'est
c'est moi je suis pour l'application
intelligente des vidéos et ça ça fait
partie des dispositions que nous
pourrions demander dans le cas d'une
loijo mais je n'irai pas jusqu'à la
reconnaissance faciale personnellement
voilà après je ne nie pas son efficacité
mais j'ai bien compris voilà bon et sur
la billetterie moi je veux pas répondre
à la question de billetterie parce que
je n'en suis pas le responsable ce que
j'ai appris aussi du Stade de France
mais je suis très heureux de m'expliquer
en amont Messieurs les Présidents de ce
qui se passe la préparation c'est que si
vous additionnez tous les organisateurs
tous ceux qui ont la responsabilité
voilà je pense que c'est important que
les organisateurs viennent de
s'expliquer devant vous sur notamment
une partie de vos recommandations qui ne
relève pas stricto sensu bien sûr du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc la
billetterie la blockchain appliquée à la
billetterie comment on utilise des
billets c'est très intéressant je m'y
intéresse personnellement mais je n'en
suis pas l'organisateur voilà donc bien
sûr moi ce qu'il faut que je regarde
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait en cas de
problème d'ordre public si la
billetterie fonctionne pas ça c'est un
scénario que nous devons moderniser mais
l'organisation de la biotique en tant
que telle je pense que les responsables
seront les mieux placés comme pour la
sécurité privée je veux pas trop faire
de commentaires parce que aujourd'hui la
fête la filière professionnelle qui se
structure est quand même assez efficace
elle recrute beaucoup je moi je veux
dire que c'est des beaux métiers que
ceux de la sécurité privée comme
énormément de potentiels pour demain et
après-demain ils payent mieux leurs
salariés c'est une bonne chose je veux
aussi dire que ça dépend beaucoup de
l'appel d'offres lancées par
l'organisateur parce que chacun sait que
moins on lance des appels d'offres avec
des montants pour les marchés moi vous
avez des gens qui payent bien alors
salarié et donc moi vous avez des gens
qui viennent répondre à ses appels donc
ce n'est pas l'état je le rappeler ici
qui fait les appels d'offres qui montent
les prix et qu'ils lancent c'est
l'organisateur donc je crois que
l'organisateur avec une discutons
évidemment de ça mais sans avoir de
contrainte est à votre est à votre
disposition j'imagine
je vous précise monsieur le ministre
qu'on a engagé une mission d'information
au niveau de la commission de la culture
qui est confiée à Claude Kern et David
Assouline sur les Jeux Olympiques donc
il paralympiques on va prendre toutes
vos questions mais chers collègues en
commençant donne toute la liste Michel
Savin Laurence haribet Jean-Jacques
Lauzac
Usain Bourgis Thomas do su Jacqueline ne
stashporino Céline Boulle espéronier
Cédric Vial et Jérémy Baki
merci monsieur le Président je vais
aller très rapidement aux questions
d'abord c'est vraiment remarqué que que
à la présentation de Monsieur le
Ministre
et je crois que c'est ici aussi des du
rapport qui j'ai fait suite aux
incidents du Stade de France l'opération
anti délinquance était nécessaire dans
le cas d'une anticipation de ce qui peut
arriver et je crois que ce qui n'avait
pas été anticipé pour le Stade de France
il est bon d'entendre aujourd'hui qui
est des opérations
d'antidélingquence qui moi mis en place
assez rapidement en amont des Jeux
Olympiques moi j'ai deux questions la
première concerne est-ce que le
ministère votre ministère est-ce que
votre dans votre mission vous aurez à la
possibilité de contrôler le Nord
habilité des 45 000 volontaires parce
que tous ne seront pas dans des stades
beaucoup de volontaires vont avoir des
missions à l'extérieur des stades sur
l'accueil des des spectateurs dirigés et
spectateurs dans les transports est-ce
que vous aurez vous un œil sur le Nord
habilité de ces 45 000 volontaires qui
quand même auront un rôle important
qui vont être recruté par le kojob
deuxième question
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que que
beaucoup de gendarmes et de policiers
elle est affectée sur cette opération
sécurité Jo donc ça veut dire que des
gendarmes qui sont aujourd'hui dans des
qui sont dans des briquables
territoriales vont être délocalisées sur
Paris ou sur d'autres sites dans des
périodes où sur certains départements
c'est des périodes oui août avec des
sites touristiques alors la question que
vous avez tout à l'heure développé un
dispositif comme quoi les agents pendant
ces périodes qui sont affectés sur le
secteur paris et jeux olympiques ne
pourront pas prendre de vacances ce que
j'ai compris est-ce que le même
dispositif va être parce que si dans les
brigades il y a moins de gendarmes qui
vont certains vont être affectés soit
Paris d'autres prennent des congés on
risque d'avoir des territoires qui vont
entendre sous effectif dans des périodes
compliquées avec sur des sites
touristiques et ça peut créer des
tensions dans certains territoires donc
quelle est la réponse à cette inquiétude
que peuvent avoir les élus sur une
période où des gens seront moins
présents
merci j'aimerais juste très rapidement
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit sur les
sociétés privées parce que c'est quand
même un pan important de la sécurité
alors je comprends que vous ayez vous
pouviez vous puissiez pas vous prononcer
sur la qualité aujourd'hui et vous vous
dites qu'il y a structurellement
beaucoup de beaucoup d'efforts ça on
peut le concevoir mais est-ce que vous
vous êtes donné des outils pour évaluer
suffisamment à l'avance la crédibilité
de ces sociétés pour éviter le fiasco
des Jeux de Londres en 2012 ou trois
semaines avant le départ des jeux
la société a fait faux bond et
finalement on est obligé d'appeler à la
rescousse l'armée donc voilà quels sont
les outils et la deuxième petite
question que j'ai moins vous poser en
prolongation de la réponse que vous avez
faite au président Lafont sur l'unité de
commandement donc on a bien je voudrais
juste une clarification vous avez bien
expliqué qu'à partir du moment où
c'était ça qui pouvait être organisateur
enfin ou en tout cas qu'il avait la
qualité c'était clair et net mais qu'en
est-il des compétitions à l'intérieur
des ancêtres des enceintes parce que
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte que
les débordements ont souvent lieu
beaucoup plus à l'intérieur des
enceintes qu'à l'extérieur et c'est
souvent dû à la fragilité des stadiers
et des séquelles et des des sociétés
privées et que du coup on a un peu
l'impression qui a une il y a une
tendance à envoyer le mistigri à
l'intérieur des enceintes sportives et
non pas à l'extérieur donc je veux jouer
juste une clarification est-ce que cette
chaîne de commandement elle est valable
pour la totalité de de l'événement
Jean-Jacques Lauzac
oui je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord pour tirer les enseignements de
ce qui s'est passé au Stade de France
pour tous les gésis à tous les grands
événements sportifs internationaux à
venir on a beaucoup parlé c'est vrai des
JO et notamment la cérémonie d'ouverture
on n'a pas parlé d'un aspect monsieur le
ministre c'est la sécurité du parcours
du relais de la flamme olympique parce
que effectivement il y a aussi là un
problème de sécurité qui va se poser il
y a une préconisation qui a été exprimée
par la Cour des comptes c'est de confier
ce volet là la gendarbrerie nationale
contenue de son expérience sur la
sécurisation des étapes du Tour de
France dont je voudrais avoir votre
votre sentiment là-dessus deuxième chose
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué la
formation les effectifs etc j'ai une
question très précise c'est quel est
l'état d'avancement de la création en
1900 Georges du centre de formation et
d'entraînement au maintien de l'ordre
pour la préfecture de police qui
n'existait pas jusqu'ici
troisièmement on est enfin moi j'ai un
petit peu surpris parce que on a bien
compris que le volet sécurité serait
présent dans la future loi olympique
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que sera
débattu notamment la question du recours
à l'intelligence artificielle et à la
reconnaissance faciale alors qu'il
semblait que suite à cette réunion du
mois de juillet autour du président de
la République la question avait été
tranchée avec une opposition au recours
à la reconnaissance faciale donc vous
nous confirmez aujourd'hui monsieur
ministre que la question n'est pas
encore tranchée enfin une question
annexe puisque tout à l'heure on parlait
des gésis les gésis c'est notamment le
Mondial au Qatar dans quelques jours et
il y a cet accord de coopération
bilatérale qui a été passée entre la
France et le Qatar et qui s'applique à
partir de la semaine prochaine
et cela donc entraîne la mobilisation de
230 agents de police français qui vont
participer à cet effort de sécurité et
il semblerait me ce ministre qu'à ce
jour l'annexe financière qui précise des
conditions sous tendance aux partenariat
ne soit toujours pas publié le
sera-t-elle un jour et si oui à quelle
date et pouvez-vous nous confirmer
également que le coût de la quelle sera
s'il y a un coût pour la France le coût
de cette opération est-ce qu'il sera
réellement neutre pour notre pays
merci beaucoup monsieur les présidents
monsieur le ministre instruit des
incidents qui ont eu lieu au Stade de
France le 28 mai dernier et sur la mise
en cause de nos services par les
autorités britanniques en particulier je
voulais savoir est-ce que
une coopération est envisagée avec les
pays dont on pourrait venir l'essentiel
des des supporters dans notre pays à la
fois pour des raisons de
pour des raisons d'encadrement pour des
raisons d'identification de ces
supporters aussi là il y a la barrière
de la langue est-ce qu'il y a une
coopération qui envisageait par exemple
à l'échelle européenne avec d'autres
forces de sécurité qui pourraient
accompagner non seulement les les
sportifs mais aussi et surtout les
supporteurs qui pourraient accompagner
les sportifs merci
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voulais revenir sur votre votre histoire
de vidéo surveillance intelligente et
sur les algorithmes que vous comptez
utiliser pour pour cette vidéo
surveillance intelligente dit
intelligente on a compris qu'il fallait
une nouvelle base juridique ça va
prendre du temps
d'y arriver
ces algorithmes aussi besoin de temps
pour être testé et être opérationnel
est-ce que vous allez les tester en
amont mais alors pour ça il va falloir
aller très vite sur la nouvelle base
législative pour les utiliser est-ce que
ces algorithmes sont ceux qui ont été
qui font partie de la liste de l'appel à
projet de la NR de 2019 sur le les
algorithmes de gestion des foules et
puis une question un peu plus
philosophique là-dessus est-ce que si on
fait reposer une partie de notre
sécurité sur ces algorithmes est-ce
qu'on ne se met pas quelque part à la
merci d'attaque cyberbe parce que vous
en avez parlé qui pourrait complètement
paralyser notre gestion des mouvements
de foule si on fait reposer une grande
partie de de notre sécurité là dessus et
puis comme on est un peu dans une
audition droite suite par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé au Stade de France j'ai
quelques petites questions
précises là dessus où est-ce qu'on en
est sur l'enquête sur les deux agents
que vous avez dés ici comme ayant fait
un usage disproportionné du gaz
lacrymogène
combien de plaintes ont été recueillies
en Angleterre et ou en somme nous c'est
pour rassurer un peu les spectateurs
étrangers qui pourraient être inquiets
là-dessus et puis une dernière question
est-ce que nos agents vont être formés
en langue anglaise pour pouvoir
éventuellement gérer plus facilement les
spectateurs internationaux je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le Président oui moi
j'avais deux questions la première
concerne les camélia rod vidéoprotection
qui sont de 4000 à Paris aujourd'hui et
je crois que vous allez les augmenter au
nombre de 400 c'est ça pour les géo ce
qui ne me semble pas énorme et je
voulais savoir si vous aviez une idée
des endroits où elles aident à augmenter
vous savez qu'une des un des reproches
qu'on fait au dispositif de caméras de
vidéoprotection à Paris c'est qu'elles
sont concentrées dans les
arrondissements du centre au détriment
des arrondissements peut-être plus
criminogènes de de la périphérie de
Paris et savoir si vous saviez à peu
près où vous allez les mettre si ce
chiffre était définitif et si évidemment
ce dispositif allait être pérenne si ce
serait une excellente chose puisque les
élus parisiens que nous sommes réclament
souvent à corps et accries plus de
caméras de vidéos protection et la
deuxième question concernait
[Musique]
la deuxième la deuxième question
concernait les
la circulation des Parisiens et vous
faisiez référence monsieur le ministre à
l'accès des logements des Parisiens
notamment sur les îles au milieu de la
Seine lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture
savoir s'il y avait des dispositifs
particuliers qui seraient mis en place
de manière générale pour l'accès au
logement des Parisiens dans certains
quartiers et enfin une petite une petite
remarque pour la conclusion vous disiez
vous-même que vous ne vous n'aviez pas
de cahier des charges précis notamment
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture et je
voulais savoir il me semble important
d'en avoir un à quel moment vous allez
mettre la pression sur la mairie de
Paris les organisateurs pour en avoir un
puisque nous avons tous été évoqué que
l'anticipation et la clé de la réussite
de cet événement mondiale je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le Président trois
petites questions j'essaie d'être rapide
alors concernant effectivement monsieur
le ministre la cérémonie d'ouverture
vous avez précisé que vous comptiez sur
la mairie de Paris avec le recrutement
de 3000 policiers municipaux qui ne sont
toujours pas recrutés donc je ne sais
pas comment en un an et demi la
périphérie de Paris va recruter 3000
policiers municipaux d'autant que si je
ne me trompe pas la police municipale de
Paris n'est pas armée et que nous
connaissons tous partout des proactifs
de recrutement toutes les villes en
cherchent et là où les policiers islams
ne sont pas armés vous ne recrutez
personne parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
venir aujourd'hui vous le savez dans des
équipes où la police paypal n'est pas
armée donc ça première question ça va
être un vrai sujet deuxième question moi
je suis dans un territoire près de chez
moi nous allons accueillir toute la
délégation américaine pour les œufs
Olympiques et Paralympiques c'est-à-dire
en gros deux mois donc je voulais savoir
qu'est-ce qui a été mis en place
dans les territoires pour assurer la
sécurité de ces lieux parce que ce n'est
pas avec la police nationale que nous
avons actuellement et les politiciens
que nous pourrons assurer la sécurité de
ces délégations et troisième petite
question alors il y a un slam qui m'a
particulièrement intéressé monsieur le
ministre ne croyez pas que je suis
provocatrice à chaque fois vous venez là
c'est le slide 5 plan 0 délinquance
pendant un an on va nettoyer la banlieue
de la délinquance donc je voudrais
savoir avec quels moyens comment et
pourquoi finalement on n'a pas commencé
à faire ce plan zéro délinquance depuis
cinq ans parce que je ne vois pas
comment en un an on va régler les
problèmes de la délinquance en
Île-de-France avec en particulier et je
regarde 5000 opérations antidélingquence
donc 3500 Île-de-France donc je voulais
savoir ce que c'est ces opérations
antidélinquance et avec quels moyens
humains et judiciaire aussi vous allez
travailler pour régler ces problèmes de
délinquance
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'avais deux questions qui
qui sont plutôt liées aux conséquences
directes ou indirectes de de ces Jeux
Olympiques la première c'est plutôt un
complément à la question qui a posé mon
collègue Michel Savin sur les ce qui va
se passer finalement sur les territoires
qui vont être
déshabillés entre guillemets d'une
partie de leurs effectifs vous l'avez
dit les congés également seront seront
interdits durant cette période ce qui
veut dire que les congés vont être pris
en dehors de ces périodes et donc on va
avoir une une autre période sur cette
même année où les effectifs vont être
vont être revus à la baisse donc comment
vous avez envisagé ça sur les
territoires qui seront impactés pendant
cette période mais aussi pendant la
période où les congés devront être pris
ma deuxième question elle est concernant
les les manifestations les événements ou
les festivals qui seront interdits vous
l'avez dit pendant cette période c'est à
mon sens sans précédent on peut
comprendre
l'intérêt de cette mesure mais ma
question elle était
qui va prendre la décision de ces
annulations est-ce que ce sera le
ministère le préfet le préfet de région
préfet de département est-ce qu'il y
aura des critères qui seront affichés
est-ce que ce sera dans la loi ce que
vous avez prévu de l'inscrire dans la
loi ou est-ce que sur les JO ou est-ce
que il y aura des critères qui qui
seront mis en œuvre quand est-ce qu'on
connaîtra soit ces critères soit ses
décisions pour que les ordinateurs
puissent anticiper et est-ce que
puisqu'il s'agit d'annulation qui sont
indépendantes de la volonté de ces
organisateurs est-ce que il y aura
d'après vous des mesures de compensation
financière par exemple pour ces
organisateurs de festivals ou
d'événements pour qu'on puisse là aussi
anticiper sur sur ces questions qui
seront on comprend importantes pour la
sécurité mais sans précédent
probablement pour pour beaucoup de
grosses manifestations dans le pays
je vous remercie
ce ministre on va vous laisser répondre
à ces questions oui merci ce premier
point façon le dernier point pardon
monsieur sénateur d'abord les Jeux
Olympiques c'est pour tout le monde je
veux dire que d'abord il s'agit pas
d'interdire ou de mettre une loi pour
dire on va pas organiser tel ou tel
faite ici ou là c'est pour l'ensemble
des citoyens tout le monde a voulu les
Jeux Olympiques d'autant plus que moi
j'étais pas dans le dossier de
candidature ni la ville de Paris ni à
l'état à l'époque et je le soutiens bien
volontiers mais je pense qu'il faut pas
qu'on ait le démarche que vous avez
c'est à dire que si je pars du principe
que c'est quelque chose de descendant
que c'est l'État qui est d'origine qui
doit récompenser d'abord c'est pas très
compatible avec la réduction des
dépenses publiques que vous nous
demandez en général puis deuxièmement
c'est une proposition de dire voilà à
l'été 2024 comme on organise des jeux
olympiques et qu'il faut qu'elle
sécurité partout on demande à chacun de
faire un petit effort de décaler
quelques jours le départ du Tour de
France je crois que d'ailleurs il y a
pas de sujet particulier sur ce point
qu'elles organisations du Tour de France
voilà de décaler quelques jours la
braderie les braderie bon bah si Madame
la mère de Lille veut pas la décaler on
la décalera pas c'est pas extrêmement
grave mais enfin plus il y en a qui bien
décalé mieux ce sera parce qu'on a sur
la sécurité de tous en tout cas le musée
intérieur dit d'avance qui ne pourra pas
mettre les mêmes forces que d'habitude
l'été voilà mais je pense que chacun
peut le comprendre et puis si les gens
veulent l'organiser quand même malgré ce
sujet je le déplorerais on va essayer de
les convaincre le préfet de police a
déjà écrit semble-t-il aux élus
parisiens je crois que les préfets en
général avec le ministère de la Culture
fait des démarches auprès des élus
partout en France donc il s'agit pas
d'obliger il s'agit de travailler
ensemble à ce que les jeux soient la
meilleure réussite possible soit on
gagne ensemble sont on perd ensemble
comme disait l'autre donc je pense qu'il
faut pas avoir cette démarche de de
d'obligation il y a pas d'obligation il
y a pas de disposition législative il y
a pas d'interdiction qui est le fait que
chacun doit mettre un petit de faire un
petit peu un peu d'effort deuxième sujet
sur les effectifs
peut-être que je suis très mal exprimé à
sénatrice ou alors peut-être qu'on sait
pas du tout entendu au début de la de la
présentation ou peut-être que même
pendant l'autre mi j'ai pas été clair
non plus donc je m'en exclu que je vais
essayer de refaire très vite au départ
de notre vie monsieur le monsieur
Président nous créons des effectifs
supplémentaires alors vous dites faut
que tu as des vacances depuis 5 ans
j'ose espérer que dans le Val-d'Oise la
délinquance ne date pas de dire 5 ans ça
m'aurait ça m'étonnerait que depuis 5
ans en fait on se sont tombés dans la
délinquance et qu'avant l'urbanisme
était joyeux il y avait pas de
séparatrice et personne se faisait
harceler bon voilà je pense que faut
tous se dire madame la sénatrice que les
difficultés délinquance dans votre
territoire était très longtemps y
compris les baisses effectives au
territoire date très longtemps donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait différent bah on
augmente les effectifs et d'ailleurs ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que vous
avez voté je vous remercie une
organisation qui monte les effectifs
notamment d'ailleurs en grande couronne
parisienne et à Paris j'ai l'occasion de
dire que Paris aura mille policiers
supplémentaires dans les quatre années
qui viennent et je ne parlais que à
Paris en ville Paris je parlais même pas
la petite couronne et je parlais pas de
la grande couronne qui doit avoir aussi
ses effectifs augmentés les créations de
brigades de gendarmerie par exemple ça a
été un moment très important donc
pourquoi on lutte pas contre des
vacances avant on lutter contre la
délègue en savant mais comment on y
arrive en mettant des moyens très
importants il faut pas raisonner à à
même température de l'eau puisque par
ailleurs nous faisons des réformes très
importantes que je remercie de soutenir
d'ailleurs de la police nationale c'est
quoi la réforme de la prestation
écosystème être davantage d'effectif
davantage de lien d'investigation dans
vos territoires vous souffrez-vous de ne
pas avoir assez de PJ il faut qu'on
connecte les deux parties de notre de
notre réflexion il y a un sujet
d'investigation dans le pays de
résolution des enquêtes de taux
d'élucination de gens qu'on arrête de
trafic de drogue le point de deal qui
est en bas des communes que vous
connaissez bien il est en lien peut-être
avec le trafiquant qui est de l'autre
côté du monde et donc il y a une
nouvelle organisation les cycles
horaires moi je m'en orgueï d'être le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui a dit aux
policiers de travailler davantage et ils
le font et ils l'ont fait de la quasi
intégralité de manière s moins de 5% des
commissariats qui n'ont pas passé au
cycle horaire qui leur donnait moins de
congés donc ils ont fait ce travail ils
sont plus présents sur la voie sur la
voie publique ils vont continuer à
l'être la réserve de la police nationale
c'est un point très très important on
n'avait pas de réserve comme la
gendarmerie en avait on commence à
recruter des articles de presse
fleurissent sur le fait qu'on arrive à
avoir les avantages de policiers à un
moment donné particulier puis surtout la
Love Me que vous avez voté ces 3000
effectifs chaque année c'est-à-dire que
pendant le quinquennat précédent on en a
formé à peu près 1500 c'est à dire que
les deux premières années on va doubler
le nombre d'effectif qui était lui-même
doublé par rapport aux années
précédentes donc on va arriver une masse
de policier dans les commissariats et
les brigades de gendarmerie qui n'ont
pas qui n'ont pas d'équivalent alors
après on lissera les congés mais c'est
pas la première fois que les
fonctionnaires de la République pour des
raisons de ça explique c'est pour ça que
c'est beau le statut militaire et que
c'est beau le statut de fonctionnaire
c'est que moi je dois encore 5 semaines
de congés payés maintenant au CRS et aux
gendarmes mobiles avant même les Jeux
Olympiques là maintenant je dois 5
semaines de congés payés depuis le 1er
janvier je constate il y a je trouve
qu'il y a pas beaucoup d'endroits où les
gens on leur doit cinq semaines de
congés payés ils disent rien ils font
pas grève et ils continuent à les
envoyer dans vos envois donc je pense
qu'on peut aussi compter sur le
patriotisme des fonctionnaires de police
et gendarmerie pour comprendre on verra
si on accompagnera ça peut-être de prix
mais on va en trouver un travail social
important auprès d'eux de lisser leur
départ en vacances ce sera pas tout tout
après enfin je pense qu'il faut
caricaturer les choses je vais leur dire
que non les brigades de gendarmerie
l'idée c'est pas d'envoyer des gens de
la brigade de gendarmerie de de de de
d'Aven sur elle peut
à Saint-Denis l'idée c'est par exemple
qu'on disait psygues les psy c'est leur
travail je crois en partie d'intervenir
dans des endroits particuliers donc le
gendarme de la brigade territoriale il a
pas vocation à venir à Saint-Denis en
revanche le PSIG c'est une possibilité
ou alors le gendarme à brigade
territoriale de la commune X à vocation
à prendre le temps des Jeux Olympiques
la commune y carrosone police qui est
juste à côté de sa zone de gendarmerie
d'ailleurs en général on se bat pour
qu'on redécoupe les zones de police
gendarmerie voilà voilà un bel exemple
temporaire donc il s'agit pas évidemment
de bouger les brigades territoriales
d'ailleurs je veux vous dire ici que par
ailleurs on aura créé plus de 3000
postes de gendarmes brigade de Brienne
territoriale donc y compris dans la
création de brigades de gendarmerie dans
vos territoires je vais parfois dire
vous voulez une nouvelle brigade dans le
sud de votre département ce sera fin
2024 parce que les sorties d'écoles
seront utilisées pour compenser les Jeux
Olympiques et puis Jeux Olympiques
passés j'aurai les effectifs que je
pourrais directement infectés dans vos
brigades territoriales donc il y aura
pas de
sous-effectif de sécurité
l'été à l'exception et je l'ai dit des
CRS des plages que j'ai évoqué que je ne
peux pas mettre en place mais moi je
pense que je dois faire au moins pudique
c'est faire des choix et chacun le
comprendra sur l'honorabilité des 45000
volontaires c'est pour ça qu'on a
réformé le CNAPS alors d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que j'essaie de commencer par le
pays mais en fait depuis la loi sécurité
globale de préparant les Jeux Olympiques
donc politique publique par politique du
ministère d'intérieur je réforme pour
pouvoir être prêt pour les jeux et ce
sera l'héritage des jeux d'ailleurs si
je veux dire de faire tout cela donc on
a fait quoi on a fait dans sécurité
globale une ordonnance sur le CNAPS ce
qu'on a d'ailleurs rendu en dur le CNAPS
il contrôle tous les agents de sécurité
privée toutes les personnes qui sont
dans les stades ça répond aussi à la
question de de Madame la madame la
sénatrice sur les stadier par exemple on
va tous dépasser grâce à une
augmentation d'effectifs et grâce aux
augmentations de compétences du CNAPS
aux fichier comme on dit pour voir si
ces personnes ont effectivement
l'honorabilité voilà donc tous les tous
les endroits je dis aussi à Monsieur
tous les endroits où le agréé par le CIO
par par le comité d'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques seront tous les toutes
les personnes seront passées au fichier
voilà donc ça c'est la réforme du CNAPS
ce que vous nous avez autorisé à faire
dans la sécurité globale qui d'ailleurs
devient de plus en plus efficace et qui
va de pair avec la professionnalisation
de la sécurité privée je rappelle que la
sécurité privée nous avons aussi
augmenter le nombre de compétences et le
nombre de moyens de contrôle notamment
sur les étrangers qui ont des cartes de
séjour aujourd'hui on a augmenté si je
veux dire le nombre d'années qu'il doit
y avoir sur le territoire national pour
pouvoir voir ses cartes ils doivent pas
votre casier judiciaire ils doivent
parler français ils doivent être
conformes aux valeurs de la République
on doit pouvoir les distinguer ça aussi
c'est la professionnalisation de la
filière qu'on a fait évidemment pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de problème qui
viennent aussi des agents de sécurité
privée après il faut pas non plus jeter
le bébé avec du bien c'est juste dire je
rappelle comme c'est un agent de
sécurité privée qui est mort en premier
quasiment dans les attentats du Stade de
France et c'est lui qui a empêché la
personne de rentrer avec la bombe dans
le stade il faut pas renverser la charge
de la preuve je sais que vous avez pas
dit mais je pense que c'est un point
très très important sur
gendarme aussi que je pense que j'ai
répondu sur la sécurité privée aussi la
question était posée sur le la vidéo au
sens large sur l'intelligence
artificielle moi je m'inspire dès que
d'excellents rapports du sénateur de
braise et du sénateur Hervé qui qui me
pousse d'ailleurs monsieur le président
de la commission des lois a posé de
telles dispositions donc j'ai toujours
dit et je le redis à Monsieur le Zac que
oui nous ne proposons pas de
reconnaissance artificielle
voilà après je sais pas je vous ai pas
vu la réunion avec le président de la
République mais vous allez dire de
particulièrement informé mais je
regarderai bien autour de la table avant
prochaine fois en revanche nous n'avons
pas dit que nous ne proposions pas
d'amélioration de disposition sur les
caméras de vidéoprotection d'abord le
Conseil d'État la CNIL nous demande de
mettre à jour le système de vidéo soyons
avec le rgpd donc il y a un travail
parlementaire extrêmement important à
faire et deuxièmement on aura un débat
sur la reconnaissance
faciale sans doute mais qui n'est pas la
proposition du gouvernement une
intelligence artificielle alors comment
on fait pour pour tester etc mais alors
je vais vous dire quelque chose il y a
plein de communes de France qui le font
déjà la question de savoir c'est est-ce
que le fond légalement mais il y a plein
de commissariat municipaux je mets des
guillemets puisque c'est une compétences
politiquesicipales qui utilisent des
logiciels qui permettent de voir la
voiture qui a 3 heures du matin entre 3h
et 4h du matin roule vite au coin de la
rue et toute jaune voilà ça ça existe
déjà il y a un vide juridique la
question est de savoir si personne n'a
jamais attaqué l'utilisation de ces
logiciels est-ce que c'est légal pas en
tout cas pour l'État nous utilisons des
choses que lorsque la loi expressément
de l'autorise qui est à mon avis une
bonne chose et donc nous demanderons
cette autorisation est donc on a plein
d'exemples de fonctionnement de ce
système est-ce que
nous allons mettre notre gestion des
foules que sur l'intelligence
artificielle la réponse est non moi j'ai
l'occasion de vous dire Monsieur le
Sénateur que pour moi ça ne servira à
aider la salle de commandement la salle
de supervision a retrouvé plus
rapidement une personne un geste par
exemple vous savez dans ces logiciels
intelligence artificielle il y a quand
on casse un abribus l'écran ressort
particulièrement parmi les 300 400 500
600 caméras qui sont devant vous et qui
met voilà là c'est là où la rébus est
cassé parfois c'est la revue c'est pas
cassé quelqu'un a acheté son sac un peu
fortement et du coup l'opérateur dit bah
non c'est pas dans les bus cassé mais ça
peut être l'occasion de regarder que bah
tiens il y a des ordres publics il faut
peut-être envoyer des policiers là si
jamais c'est le si jamais c'est le c'est
le cas
sur la ville de Paris bon je vois qu'il
y a un débat entre entre vous donc je
vais vous laisser mais je voudrais dire
la salatrice que oui elles sont pérennes
ces caméras donc il y a pas de problème
400 c'est déjà beaucoup
je crois que Madame la Maire de Paris et
le préfet de police discute en ce moment
même de savoir où est-ce qu'il les
implantent je voudrais quand même dire
que la Ville de Paris est l'ensemble
d'ailleurs du site parisien ne sont pas
sous équipés on est à 4171 caméras
actuellement à Paris donc à peu près
plus de 400 j'ai dit que si il fallait
davantage on les mettrai davantage il y
a 3500 caméras des partenaires
directement sur la voie publique ou en
lien avec les spectateurs SNCF RATP par
exemple voilà et donc on a quand même un
petit dizaine de minutes un peu moins
d'une dizaine de milliers de caméras
plus les caméras voiries
mais je le rappelle je n'ai pas de
problème voilà avec ça j'ai l'occasion
de dire que je crois que j'ai pas j'ai
pas d'échanges idéologiques sur ces
questions la question de savoir est-ce
qu'on les met je proposerai que le
préfet de police une fois qu'il aura
négocié avec la Ville de Paris puisse
peut-être de présenter un ensemble des
élus ça me paraît logique je le rappelle
ici mais j'ai pas la même échange avec
la paire de Paris qu'avec d'autres mères
et qui pose plus de problèmes ça veut
dire idéologique sur la question des
caméras
je vais pas en rajouter mais chacun le
chacal comprendra donc dans la ville de
Paris je crois qu'on a pas de sujets et
s'il faut sans caméra de plus on mettra
son camera plus c'est pas en soi un
problème après ce sont des caméras qui
effectivement sont là pour l'ordre
public terrorisme la lutte contre les
vacances bon c'est sûr qu'il y aura pas
de caméra dans chaque rue de Paris mais
il n'y a jamais une caméra dans chaque
rue d'une commune sur la question
de la police municipale et les parts
c'est vrai mais c'est un choix strict de
la ville de Paris et de son conseil
municipal de pas le faire donc je
constate que c'est nous qui avons
autorisé si je veux dire Paris avoir une
police municipale c'est comme un fait
historique c'est un point important on a
toujours dit qu'on était très très
favorable à ce point moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer pour dire que
je pense que c'est mieux que la ville
capitale les policiers municipaux après
formation ce soir armé mais je respecte
profondément le choix de chaque commune
de délibérée comme il l'entend en tout
cas
nous prenons la police municipale
organisée recruté par Madame Hidalgo tel
quel je sais pas tout à fait certain
qu'on puisse comparer avec d'autres
communes avec des mercato de dire comme
ça des possibilités parce que ce que
j'ai compris David de Paris c'est
qu'elle utilisait souvent des policiers
pardon des personnes qui étaient déjà
dans son personnel et notamment le des
aides au stationnement et les faisait
monter en compétences donc ils ont quand
même la ville de Paris il y a une
fonction publique très particulière au
sens suit générisent du terme elle les
fait monter en compétences donc c'est
pas des recrutement des policiers
municipaux classiques mais voilà moi je
suis pas là pour recruter la police
municipale par de la ville de Paris
évidemment
d'ailleurs je crois que je me suis
Assouline est heureux que c'est tout bon
qui soit déjà mettre déontologue de la
police municipale de Paris par un énorme
retournement de l'histoire monsieur
l'insuline et prends prends des conseils
j'étais sur le collaborateur j'ai aucun
problème c'est pour aujourd'hui que ça
c'est Monsieur tout bon qui donne
désormais des des recommandations de
déontologie à Monsieur monsieur monsieur
monsieur
la délégation
je crois que j'ai répondu à la plupart
de vos questions sur le Qatar
sur le Qatar sur le Qatar ça ne coûte
rien à la France en tant que telle il ne
s'agit pas il ne s'agit pas de de
délibération
publique mais effectivement signé je
voudrais rappeler que les 200 gendarmes
notamment qui sont au Qatar c'est pour
répondre notamment à la question que
poser monsieur le sénateur sur la
coopération internationale c'est aussi
et surtout pour aider les Français qui
sont quand même un certain nombre à
commencer par notre équipe nationale à
être sur place donc quand j'entends
parfois des critiques sur le fait que
les gendarmes sont au Catard bah oui ils
aident les Français qui portent plainte
ceux qui seraient accusés ceux qui ont
besoin de soutien consulaires et
notamment notre équipe de football qui
qui a besoin d'être protégé donc il nous
accueillerons évidemment des policiers
des gendarmes du monde entier et nous
travaillerons en coopération avec eux je
ne suis pas certain que
il y avait polémique sur ce point et je
crois monsieur le Président que j'étais
complet merci monsieur le ministre avant
de suspendre la Réunion une dernière
question à quelle date pensez-vous
déposer le texte sur les Jeux Olympiques
alors je ne sais pas parce que d'abord
ce n'est pas moi qui le porterai à titre
principal le deuxième monde nous avons
une d'autres réunions d'arbitrage et que
la première mise dans les jours les
semaines qui viennent pardon
je ne suis pas maître de l'agenda
parlementaire qui change au fur et à
mesure des articles 49 alinéa 3
appliqués à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons suivi l'actualité mais je crois
que dans un certain temps comme dirait
le l'humoriste de ma commune
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci cher collègue nous levons la
science à la commission des lois s'en va
mais cru comprendre que la Commission
d'affaires culturelles reste merci